[Musique]
Olivier Marlex, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement s'il
vous plaît ?
Bien Olivier Marlex, j'ai 48 ans. Je
suis député de Reloire, député des
Républicains.
Je
je suis originaire de du Cantal. J'ai
grandi entre l'Auvergne et et la région
parisienne.
Vous êtes né à Boulogne ?
Je suis né à Boulogne très 71
il y a donc 48 ans à peu près. Euh
voilà, j'ai je fais mes études
supérieures à Prbac à Paris sur SP. Je
fais un DEA de droit public en Auvergne.
Voilà. Puis après, j'ai pas mal hésité
entre l'engagement dans l'administration
ou l'engagement plutôt politique.
Don j'ai alterné en fait. Mon premier
patron était Charles Pasquais au Sénat
quand j'étais tout jeune, je vais avoir
18 19 ans. Voilà. Après, je suis parti
sur une vie plus professionnel
professionnel plus administrative.
J'étais patron des services d'un d'un
département celui où je suis élu
aujourd'hui. J'étais conseiller d'un
président de la République s'appelait
qui était Nicolas Sarkozi, conseiller
min de l'intérieur Claude Guérand. Et
depuis 2012 donc je suis je suis député
élu en 2012, réélu en 2017 membre de la
commission des lois. Voilà.
président d'une commission d'enquête.
Non.
Et j'ai présidé une commission d'enquête
sur notamment les décisions de l'État en
matière de de politique industrielle.
commission d'enquête d'ailleurs qui
avait été demandé par tous les groupes
de de l'Assemblée nationale après la
vente d'Alstom y
compris la République en marche
la République en marche ne s'est pas
opposé à la demande. La la demande de
création de la commission d'enquête
avait vraiment été déposée par tous les
groupes, les communistes, la France
insoumise, l'UDI, les Républicains. La
République en marche ne s'est pas opposé
à la constitution de la commission
d'enquête qui qui relev des droits de
tirage de de de l'opposition, mais elle
a pas voulu elle a pas fait obstacle.
Euh, on visa clairement d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de de fusion acquisition
de ventes qui ont été autorisées par
l'État. On regard peut-être cette notion
de d'autorisation par l'État euh dans
les années 2014-26,
notamment euh Alstom Power, euh Alcatel,
Techniip, euh la vente de la farge, euh
chacune de ces ventes représentant des
sommes très très importantes, hein,
c'est des fusions acquisition.
Alstom c'était 12 milliards 12 milliards
3, Alcatel 15 milliards, Technipp 9
milliards, la Farge 18 milliards. Donc
pas des pas des petites opérations et on
a un peu le sentiment qu'il y a une
accélération de l'histoire d'ailleurs à
ce moment-là dans le dans le monde de la
fusion acquisition pendant ces deux
années qui correspondent aux deux années
de d'ailleurs de présence de d'Emmanuel
Macron, ministère de de l'économie pour
pour l'essentiel.
Voilà. Donc moi ce qui m'intéressait en
particulier, je me suis en vieux en
vieux gauliste,
je m'intéressa à la la question depuis
assez longtemps de comment on protège
nos florons industriels dans ce pays. On
est un pays
qui compte un certain nombre de
Avant que je vous laisse dérouler, ça
veut dire quoi vieux gauliste ? Bon, ça
veut dire que le la base de mon
engagement euh politique, c'est vraiment
euh c'est le c'est le c'est-à-dire c'est
croire euh c'est c'est c'est croire que
que la France là euh c'est pas un vieux
machin, un vieux truc qui appartient au
passé, mais croire que que la France,
elle a elle a peut-être un rôle un peu
particulier à tenir dans le dans le
monde qu'elle a qu' a un sombre de
messages pour et qu'il faut pas renoncer
faut pas renoncer à défendre ce qu'est
cette conception de de de la France.
Donc en matière en matière économique
notamment, ça veut dire euh ça veut dire
considérer que euh il faut aujourd'hui
se battre pour préserver ce qui fait euh
euh ce qui ce qui sont les outils de
notre de notre souveraineté euh de notre
indépendance nationale euh qui a été
d'ailleurs constitué souvent avant même
le retour au pouvoir du général de
Gaulle. Le programme le programme
nucléaire par exemple effectivement il a
été poursuivi pendant toute la 4e
République, ça date pas de ça date pas
de 58 euh et qu'il faut pas brader tout
ça. Et le général de Gaulle dans ses
mémoires d'espoir dit "Quand je reviens
dit quand je reviens au pouvoir en 1958
je découvre que qu'il n'y en a que pour
le le supranational la tentation la
fascination pour le supranational et que
défendre la France finalement ça
n'intéresse plus personne." Je crois que
c'est un petit peu ça le sujet
d'ailleurs dont on qui était derrière
euh derrière notre commission d'enquête,
les travaux de notre commission
d'enquête.
Là, à un moment euh sur une des vidéos
que qu' y a sur internet où vous
exprimez dessus, vous parlez de
quelqu'un qui s'appelle Bernard
Ézambert.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
Bernard Ézamember ? Alors, il a fait le
programme thermonucléaire avec Pompidou,
c'est ça ? Sur
Bernardbert, il a été
on connaît, c'est pour ça.
D'accord. Donc, c'est un monsieur un peu
âgé maintenant. Il a plus de 80 ans euh
mais il est d'une il a conservé une
parfaite agilité euh intellectuelle, je
rassure. Il a été le conseiller
économique de George Pompidou à Matignon
et à l'Élysée. Et donc il a vraiment
porté accompagné
tous les grands programmes industriels
français, que ce soit effectivement le
le secteur nucléaire
mais aussi le programme du TGV,
l'aérospatial,
Airbus, tout ça c'est vraiment des
programmes qui ont pris toutes leur
toutes le leur r leur essort pardon à
cette à cette époque-là. Et après, c'est
quelqu'un qui a une une poursuite de
carrière plutôt dans le monde de la
finance euh dans une des des maisons
Rothshield. Euh donc il y a un regard
très très complet sur sur ce que doit
être l'industrie et sur le rôle que que
le politique peut jouer dans
l'industrie. Moi ce que je trouve très
intéressant quand je discute avec lui,
c'est que à aucun moment il n'ose
ce que doit être le le le monde de la de
la finance dont on a dont on a besoin
pour financer pour financer l'économie.
avec une une volonté industrielle. Euh
moi j'ai j'ai l'intime conviction et
d'ailleurs quand quand on quand on
regarde un peu les les grands exemples
industriels soit en France ou ailleurs,
même dans l'actualité très très récente,
vous n'avez pas de vraie grande réussite
industrielle sans à un moment une
complicité particulière avec la
puissance publique. Regardez la la la 5G
en Chine par exemple, c'est pas une
création spontanée du marché la 5G en
Chine. C'est sont des programmes publics
chinois. C'est financé par de la
recherche publique universitaire. Euh,
prenez les les GAFA aux États-Unis. Les
GAFA ne sont pas nés, ne sont pas des
créations totalement spontanée du
marché. Euh d'après ce que j'ai compris
lu sur le sujet, elles ont bénéficié
d'accompagnement euh de financement par
des programmes militaires ou de
renseignement euh américain. Donc euh
même dans les pays les plus euh euh
enfin dans un pays libéral comme les
États-Unis, euh j'ai la la puissance la
puissance publique joue un rôle
d'accompagnement. Donc Bernard Ezambert
qui est un des premiers à introduire le
mot intelligence économique en France.
Guerre économique
guerre économique euh et Robert Guillomo
sur les question de renseignement
économique. Ouais. Euh euh est-ce que
vous pensez que la France à l'heure
actuelle quand on se fait découper euh
notre filière notre filière nucléaire,
quand on est en train de se faire
découper EDF, quand on est en train de
se faire découper tous nos fleurons,
votre interprétation c'est on est dirigé
par euh une bande de bran qui n'ont
aucune idée de comment se passe une
guerre économique avec un prisme de
lecture qui est de l'échelle de leur
prochain mandat
où on est Euh piloté par une banque de
branques qui font acte de forfaiture,
c'estàd qui vendent la France à la
découpe au même titre que l'exUnion
Soviétique quand elle s'est effondrée.
Tout tous ces fleurons ont été découpés
et
donnés à des oligarques
ou simplement
la France fait des des bons paris et
c'était très bien de vendre Alstom et on
continue à découper la France.
Vous avez compris ? Je suis plutôt
partisan de la de la de la deuxè
émotion. D'abord, je voudrais quand même
la deuxième option
option
je pense qu'on en est pas dans un dans
un certain nombre de cas je je vais je
vais revenir je vais d'abord dire que je
dirais c'est pas une attitude générale
des pouvoirs des des des gouvernants.
Prenons le cas d'Alstom par exemple en
2004, vous avez un ministre de
l'économie qui était un type un peu
énergique qui a tout fait pour pour
sauver Alstom, qui qui a mouillé la
chemise pour convaincre la Commission
européenne qu'il fallait laisser l'État
réinjecter de l'argent. Il fallait
essayer après de de de trouver un
montage avec un grand investisseur qui
pouvait y voir de l'intérêt. Ça a été le
groupe Boué. Enfin, je parle évidemment
donc de Nicolas Sarzy, ministre ministre
de l'économie. il est pas resté il est
pas resté chaud dans cette affaire. Euh
on peut parler aussi de ce qui a été
l'action par exemple de de d'Arnaud
Mondbourg dans le sauvetage de de
Peugeot. Il il y a des moments où où on
a eu des grands ministres de l'économie
ou d'industrie qui ont envie de se
mouiller pour sauver les pour sauver les
les choses. C'est pas l'attitude
effectivement l'attitude de tout le
monde tout le temps. Et et je crois que
en France on a on a une vraie
une vraie particularité
euh une tendance une tendance de fond.
C'estàd que il y a qui qui ressort dès
que dès qu'il y a pas un ministre de
l'économie qui qui a qui a une vision un
peu forte.
que finalement en France, on a euh on a
comment dire de de très beaux flora
industriels euh que
qui ont un lien particulier en plus avec
avec l'État du Flor François Fillon qui
est d'ailleurs de votre groupe dit je
suis à la tête d'un état qui est en
faillite
ça veut dire quoi
ça c'est une référence à la capacité
financière d'agir de de de l'État on y
reviendra parce que c'est
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous pouvez me
permettre on va essayer de dresser le
tableau de la situation actuelle en
terme d'échiquier de guerre économique.
Donc quelles sont les marges de manœuvre
de la France ? Je reviens quand même sur
votre première question qui un petit
sujet. Vous parlez de forfaiture donc
c'est pas c'est pas un petit sujet. Je
crois qu'il y a dans notre pays tout
tous ceux qui devraient défendre
l'intérêt l'intérêt national
ne le font pas toujours.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire forfaiture ?
C'est vous qui avez pas le mot
forfaiture. Donc je je reste si vous
permettez
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
la forfaiture ?
C'est c'est la c'est la haute trahison.
C'est la trahison. Donc en tout cas
c'est c'est la trahison des intérêts
nationaux. La Sarkozy a pas fait enlever
le crime de haute trahison. Non, c'est
peut-être pas lui hein. Je demande à me
faire fa checker.
Ouais. Ouais. Non, je
j'avoue que je ne sais pas quoi vous
faites allusion mais bon. Euh non, très
clairement, on est euh je crois que le
quand on regarde la vente d'Alstom,
quand on regarde un certain nombre
d'autres d'autres ventes, celle d'catel,
euh de la part de l'État, c'est une
perte de c'est une perte de d'entreprise
très importantes euh et donc derrière
c'est une perte de de souveraineté. La
vente d'Alstom Power, c'est très
clairement euh le la la perte pour la
France de la capacité à entretenir de
manière autonome nos 58 réacteurs
nucléaires. Désormais, c'est les
Américains Gén électrique qui en font
qui en font l'entretien. C'est euh c'est
la perte de de de de beaucoup d'autres
choses. On n plus capable de vendre des
centrales nucléaires 100 % françaises
qui en main pour que nos auditeurs
comprennent bien votre propos. Je on va
on va les contextualiser. Admettons la
guerre en Irak. Vous vous rappelez la
guerre en Irak avec Dominique de
Villepin qui dit voilà nous sommes issu
d'un vieux pays qui a connu la guerre
nous sommes les gardiens de on ira pas
en guerre. Là on se retrouve dans la
même situation une guerre illégitime
avec des institutions internationales
qui sont un peu manipulées pour nous
pousser à la guerre. La France s'y
oppose. Là, vous êtes en train de nous
dire que la France n'a plus les
capacités d'entretenir ses réacteurs
nucléaires en mesure de rétorsion par
les Américains.
Je vais pas je vais pas si loin dans la
dans dans la réponse, mais sur prenons
le cas, je par que les Américains
iraient nous couper couper nos nos
centrales nucléaires du jour au
lendemain. Je sais pas je je vais pas
jusque là dans la dans la
science-fiction, mais de manière
beaucoup plus sciencefiction
de manière beaucoup plus
on serait on serait un niveau de
dégradation de nos relations avec les
avec les Américains qui seraiit qui
dépasse quand même un peu l'entendement
et l'imagination. Donc non, mais de
manière beaucoup plus prosaïque.
Effectivement, on peut imaginer que
demain euh les Américains se fassent euh
qui sont fournisseurs de de de turbine
pour le Charles de Gaulle dans un cas de
d'intervention militaire qui ne serait
pas partagé, vous n'aurez pas envie
qu'on envoie euh notre porte-avion et
bien euh pourrait retarder, faire
retarder leur assistance. En plus, on
est dans un secteur où l'exportation euh
l'exportation des des des armes et
cetera sont extrêmement contrôlées par
la législation américaine. Donc les
interventions de général électrique et
la fourniture de général électrique,
elle elle obéit à des euh à des comment
dire à un système juridique qui fait que
les Américains peuvent effectivement le
bloquer à tout à tout moment.
Euh non, je pense que sur sur ces
ventes, sur la façon dont dont on laisse
faire dans notre pays, pour moi
effectivement ça va ça va au-delà de
au-delà de l'incompétence, c'est une
véritable lâcheté voir des systèmes de
espèce de de trahison de de certaines
personnes qui est qui est un jeu, un
système entretenu. Alors, pour être plus
précis par exemple, moi j'ai j'ai pas
mal travaillé sur sur les questions de
de de de pantouflage de nos de nos haut
fonctionnaires. Je suis assez fasciné de
voir la facilité avec laquelle certains
haut fonctionnaires français partent
travailler soit pour des banques
d'affaires qui leuront proposé des deals
fameux. Donc on comprend quand on voit
le le saut qu'ils font en terme de de
rémunération et de tout ce qui va
derrière entre leur poste à la DG trésor
ou à la PE et le rôle dans une banque
d'affaires, on comprend la fascination
qu'ils peuvent avoir pour pour ces
banques d'affaires, qu'elles soient
françaises ou ou américaines.
Voilà. Mais il y a pas il y a pas que
ça. Ça peut être aussi un pantouflage
dans une dans une grande entreprise. Et
clairement en France jusqu'à
aujourd'hui, ce sont des choses
auxquelles on ne fait absolument pas
attention. Et je pense vraiment que le
pantouflage est utilisé comme une arme
aujourd'hui de de guerre économique.
D'ailleurs, je me souviens
il y a pas il y a pas de un délai de
latence entre les deux postes ?
Alors, il il y en a en théorie qui a été
réduit, il était de 50 autre fois. Il
n'est plus que de que de 3 ans. Et en
réalité, la commission de déontologie de
la fonction publique qui était censée
faire ce travail de vérification qui
n'est pas du conflit d'intérêt euh est
un truc qui a fait marrer tout le monde
au point d'ailleurs que nous venons de
de lui de la faire disparaître au profit
de la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique qui elle
a fait preuve de d'un peu plus de
rigueur dans son dans dans dans dans son
travail. Voilà, je crois que c'est
Jean-Louis Nadal, l'actuel président de
la haute Autorité d'ailleurs qui me
disait que le délit de prise illégale
d'intérêt euh applicable aux
fonctionnaires, c'estàd ce délit de
pantouflage fait que vous alliez dans
une entreprise sur laquelle vous avez
donné des avis, des conseils et cetera,
euh laquelle vous avez guidé la main
publique avant de partir, euh bien je
crois n a donné lieu qu'à 5 ou six
poursuites en 100 ans. Donc autant dire
que c'est une loi qui n'a jamais été
appliquée très sérieusement en France.
Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ? Oui, parce que très
clairement ça fait partie de ça fait
partie de de de cet entre qui arrange
trop de monde, trop d'intérêt et
d'intérêt d'intérêt économique très
puissant derrière qui fait que beaucoup
de gens ont laissé ont fermé les yeux.
Pourtant le diagnostic, il est il est il
est partagé, il est largement partagé.
Je me souviens même d'une d'une
interview d'Emmanuel Macron au journal
La Croix pendant la campagne
présidentielle. Je crois que c'était
autour du du 15 avril euh de 2017 où il
explique qu'il y a des fonctions de
souveraineté dans l'appareil d'État et
il cite la souveraineté militaire mais
aussi souveraineté économique et
financière euh à partir desquels il ne
faudrait pas pouvoir aller pantoufler.
Donc je pense que quand il parle de
souveraineté économique et financière,
je pense qu'il parle notamment de
pantouflage dans un certain nombre de de
ces banques d'affaires par exemple qui
organise les deals.
C'est c'est vous parlez d'entre soi. Euh
l'entre soi, ça commence où ? Ça vient
d'où ? C'est à cause de quoi ? C'est des
questions de pognon, c'est des questions
de cast, c'est des questions de grande
école, c'est des questions de d'intérêt
convergent ? Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Écoutez, moi je le regarde un peu à
l'ône des des deux trois opérations que
j'ai que j'ai que j'ai décortiqué. Mais
pour revenir très clairement à une oper
sur l'entreo mais revenir à au cas que
j'ai que que j'ai que j'ai étudié qui
est le cas de le cas d'Alstom.
On est dans un dans un cas en France où
les entreprises stratégiques ne peuvent
pas être vendu n'importe comment à
n'importe qui et il faut une
autorisation du politique. Alors c'est
notamment le décret Montbourg mais en
réalité bien avant le décret Montbourg
qui n'a fait que préciser le champ
d'application c'est une législation
avant il y avait le décret Villepin et
c'est une législation qui date de 1966
le général de Gaulle qui dit "En France
la libre circulation des capitaux est
établie. n'importe qui peut acheter. Euh
en revanche, l'État a le droit de
s'opposer dès lors qu'on les intérêts
nationaux, l'ordre public, la défense,
euh la sécurité nationale sera sera en
cause. Bon euh donc il y a un pouvoir du
ministre de s'opposer. C'est le ministre
de l'économie selon les textes qui qui
doit autoriser ou pas le rachat d'une
entreprise dans le secteur stratégique
sans contrôle parlementaire, sans rien.
Sans contrôle parlementaire, sans rien.
Et donc moi ce que j'ai regardé
d'ailleurs ce qui était vraiment ma
porte d'entrée vraiment dans la dans
l'affaire Alstom, c'était de regarder
comment dans quelles conditions cette
autorisation ministérielle qui qui
aurait dû être donné par Arnaud Monbourg
mais finalement c'est par Arnbourg dans
quelles conditions cette cette
autorisation elle est donnée et en fait
ce que je que ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
découvert qui s'est fait virer juste
avant la fin de l'opération
c'est Emmanuel Macron enfin qui
d'ailleurs pas vraiment une surprise
c'est que en France quand on veut
racheter une entreprise stratégique un
floron national important pour la
défense nationale. Bon, on va d'abord
demander aux politiques un feu vert. On
va d'abord à la présidence de la
République demander un accord et une
fois qu'on a cet accord politique, bah
on fait instruire le dossier par
l'administration.
aux États-Unis,
une telle façon de faire serait un
scandale un scandale national et
vaudrait
aux autorités qui qui
courtcircuiteraient ainsi le le le
système les les pires ennuis les pires
ennuis judiciaires parce que la
procédure dans notre droit droit d'end
droit américain, elle est parfaitement
elle est parfaitement décrite.
États-Unis en clair, vous avez un comité
qui s'appelle le le CFUS qui est le
comité pour les investissements
étrangers aux États-Unis qui examine les
enjeux liés à une vente. Et au terme de
d'un examen très précis de ces enjeux,
en clair, qu'est-ce qu'on risque de
perdre comme élément de souveraineté ?
Et en face éventuellement qu'est-ce
qu'on peut mettre comme moyen de
protection si malgré tout la vente se
fait et si on change d'investisseur ? Et
au terme de cet examen, une fois qu'on a
une solution précise en disant "OK, on
peut autoriser mais il faut s'assurer de
ça, ça et ça". Et bien le politique
prend sa décision. Euh en France, c'est
pas comme ça que ça marche, c'est
l'inverse. Et euh on va voir le
politique, on demande si euh s'il voit
pas d'objection et euh après
l'administration s'arrange pour
régulariser comme elle peut en ayant
évidemment à subir l'influence du
politique qui a déjà dit "Bon, vous avez
intérêt, on autorisera la vente." Donc
euh voilà. Donc ça c'est le contexte
juridique. Donc l'entre soi c'est le
fait déjà qu'il puisse y avoir des
contacts informels entre l'investisseur
et le décideur politique avant tout
examen administratif du du dossier avant
d'avoir décortiqué ce qui était les
enjeux importants pour pour la
souveraineté pour la défense de la
France. Voilà. Et donc c'est là que
c'est là qu' Gill entre soit. Donc très
concrètement qui est-ce qui va taper à
la table à la porte pardon du président
de la République ou de ses
collaborateurs en charge des des
dossiers économiques ? C'est soit le
vendeur, c'est un c'est un français,
soit soit une banque d'affaires qui dit
voilà on a on a une possibilité de de
deal. Est-ce que ça posera un problème
ou pas ?
Voilà, c'est comme ça que s'est passé au
terme de de l'analyse que j'en ai faite,
la la la la la la la vente la la vente
d'alst nombre de personnes sont allé
toquer à la porte de la présidence de la
République à l'époque de de de du du
président du président Hollande et on
qui
sans doute la banque d'affaires qui
était en charge du deal
probablement le l'actionnaire qui
cherchait à vendre le nom du secteur
étant facilement identifi
vous avez peur des des des des répercuss
de de ces grosses institutions qui vous
tomber dessus. Est-ce que l'État vous
protège ?
Non, il y a pas de
Je suis pas sûr que ce que je fais
aujourd'hui plairait totalement plais
totalement aux autorités de l'État
d'ailleurs.
Pourquoi donc ?
Mais
pourquoi donc ?
Pardon ?
Pourquoi ça leur plaît pas ?
par exemple le signalement que j'ai fait
auprès du parquet national auprès du
parquet à Paron de Paris sur les
conditions de cette vente et les
problèmes qu'elle qu'elle soulève de mon
point de vue, je pense pas que
enthousiasme ça enthousiasme forcément
la substance de ce signalement.
Bah, je m'interroge sur l'étrange
concomitance
qu'il y a entre d'un côté, on va dire
d'acteurs qui avaient qui sont
intervenus dans la vente d'Alstom qui
avaient intérêt à cette vente, des
acteurs qui sont rémunérés par par
successfiz. Bah, je pense aux banques
d'affaires qui ont qui ont fait ce deal.
Je pense
c'est des c'est des des volumes d'argent
de à peu près combien ?
le montant total des honoraires. Alst
déclaré euh l'autorité des marchés
financiers comme honoraire de
l'opération 0,3 milliards d'euros. Donc
300 millions d'euros. Ça c'est ce
qu'Alstom dit avoir payé comme frais
financier. Alors dedans vous avez euh
vous avez le la taxe sur les
transactions financières à 0,2 %. Donc
ça fait pas tant d'argent que ça. Tout
le reste c'est ce sont des honoraires.
Euh donc ça fait quand même beaucoup
d'argent en honoraire. Alors Altom a
préciser qu'ils avaient payé autour de
262 millions d'euros de d'honorair de
frais et que le 03 était un arrondi. Bon
voilà et puis vous avez ce que Général
électrique a payé de son côté. Patrick
j'ai interrogant point me dire bah ils
ont sans doute dépenser encore plus
d'argent que nous si j'en juge par le
nombre de personnes qui avaient autour
de la table à chacune de nos rencontres.
Donc 300 millions d'euros d'un côté,
probablement autant de l'autre, on
arrive à 600 millions d'euros, entre 5
et 600 millions, on va dire d'honorair
payés à l'occasion d'une vente comme
celle d'Alstom. Donc ça fait beaucoup
d'argent
euh déversé à l'occasion de d'un tel
d'un tel deal. Donc il y a de quoi faire
du ruissellement si Et donc pour en
revenir à mon signalement et répondre à
votre question,
du ruissellement ou du graissage ?
Moi, je me suis euh très clairement
interrogé, enfin je l'ai écrit
d'ailleurs ouvertement, euh quand on
quand on connaît les montants, quand on
découvre les montants, sont des montants
euh qui en général sont euh sont pas ne
sont pas sur la place publique. Non,
non. Alors, ils sont Oui, merci de de
préciser. Je pense qu'ils sont ils sont
en partie évidemment en grande partie
probablement justifié les cabinets
d'avocat notamment qui ont apporté les
dossiers auprès de de l'antitrust à
Bruxelles, auprès des des il y avait
dans le cas de dans le cas de de
d'alstom Power beaucoup d'autorités
antitrust à aller à aller voir. Donc il
y a il y a évidemment une grande part de
travail mais n'empêche qu'une grande
part de ces honoraires est aussi payé en
successf. Donc vous avez beau
travailler, c'est le cas des banques
d'affaires par exemple, elles ne sont
rémunérées qu'au successful. C'estàdire
que le deal ne se fait pas. En
l'occurrence le ministre de l'économie
ne signe pas la vente au bout du compte.
euh les banques d'affaires ? Non, rien
et on travaillait euh on travaillait
pour pour rien. Donc ça fait ça fait euh
ça fait effectivement beaucoup d'argent
et je me suis interroger par écrit dans
ma dans l'avant-propos de de de la du
rapport de de la commission d'enquête
sur ce qui était la la la limite euh
entre effectivement la la rémunération
des intermédiaires et vraiment une
stratégie des stratégies d'influence.
J'ai j'ai pas fait les numérations
complètes de tous les lobbyes, de toutes
les agences de communication parce que
j'ai j'ai pas eu les réponses complètes
dans le cadre de la commission
d'enquête. Mais ce que j'en ai vu c'est
c'est sans doute une mobilisation de
moyens de manière surabondante. C'est
vous avez quand j'ai créé la commission
d'enquête la commission d'enquête
pardon,
j'ai plusieurs cabinets de le bing qui
m'ont appelé en me disant mais ça va
aboutir votre demande de commission
d'enquête. J'u oui ça va vous dire
pourquoi vous avez travaillé sur ce deal
bah oui oui on a travaillé dessus et en
fait vous vous rendez compte qu'il y
avait énormément énormément énormément
de monde dessus y compris des gens qui
je pense on ont cru travailler n'ont pas
forcément été forcément très utiles au
deal mais le fait qu'il soit rémunéré
par danse d'al faisait en tout cas qu'il
n'était pas disponible pour au service
d'une d'une cause adverse.
Voilà ce qui amenait Arnaud Monbourg
employer cette expression sans laquelle
tout Paris était loué et je pense que je
pense qu'il a il a il a il a il a pas
tort dans d'utiliser cette expression
c'est qu'il y avait il y avait plus
personne de disponible à Paris pour pour
soutenir une thèse inverse et dire que
ce deal était cette vente talstom
étrique était était un mauvais deal donc
oui je pense que l'argent qui est
déversé dans certaines opération c'est
le cas notamment d'stom va probablement
au-delà de la simple rémunération du
travail effectué mais va mais permet
d'alimenter une vraie stratégie
d'influence fait travailler des gens
on fait travailler des gens pour les
neutraliser. Voilà
donc c'est pas de la corruption c'est
juste de l'influence.
Alors mon mon signalement lui il va
effectivement un tout petit peu plus
loin. Là ce que je viens de vous décrire
c'est ce à quoi je m'étais arrêté
à la fin de la commission d'enquête qui
a rendu son rapport de mémoire vers le à
la mi-avril 2018.
que j'ai découvert par la suite, c'est à
travers les Macron notamment qui ont été
exploités par la par la presse, c'est
finalement que il y avait des résonances
assez étranges euh en tout cas trouvant
plus entre des des structures juridiques
qui avaient bénéficié de cette vente et
d'un côté qui était que j'avais moins
identifié comme étant intéressé à la
vente d'Alstom et euh des donateurs de
la campagne de monsieur Macron, des gens
qui se sont mobilisés aussi pour des
dîners de de de levée de fond.
Effectivement, ce le ce rapprochement
entre ces deux éléments m'a paru
suffisamment gênant pour euh pour pour
que je fasse ce signalement auprès du du
parquet de Paris.
Donc le c'est le parquet national
financier, c'est ça.
Moi, j'ai fait un signalement parce que
je l'ai fait en fait sur deux aspects,
deux questions qui qui m'ont arrodé
après cette commission d'enquête.
premier, c'est celui-là. euh
fait qu'on retrouve des des des acteurs
mobilisés au service de de d'une
campagne électorale.
Et et l'autre aspect c'était c'était
pourquoi finalement en France alors que
que cette affaire Alstom a été largement
connue dans la presse que les affaires
de de de corruption pour lesquelles
Alstom SA a pé des coupables aux
États-Unis qu'ils ont reconnu que il ils
avaient commis un certain nombre de de
de
de de pardon de de faites corruption
partout à travers le monde et ça a
permis au procureur américain de faire
un communiqué de presse dans lequel il
dit euh nous avons mis un terme à la
plus grosse opération de corruption dans
l'histoire de la justice américaine
faite par donc on a Alstom SA qui
peut-être coupable de ces faits de
corruption qui aujourd'hui publiquement
n'aurait pas le droit de dire non non on
n jamais fait ça sinon il serait il
serait parjure par rapport à leur à leur
plac coupable et en France pour autant
ça n'a donné lieu à aucune aucune
investigation
donc c'est aussi cet élément là que j'ai
soulevé
auprès du parquet du parquet nation du
parquet de Paris pardon.
Pourquoi est-ce que ces effets de
corruption n'ont jamais été poursuivis
en France ? Voilà donc comme j'avais ces
deux entrées, j'ai transmis le tout au
parquet de Paris. Depuis ce que je sais
c'est que le parquet de Paris sur le le
volet
financement enfin interrogation sur le
financement d'une campagne électorale
l'a transmis comme comme la loi le
prévoit au parquet national financier
qui est seul compétent pour traiter
d'opération des opérations financières.
Vous pensez que ça va aboutir ou c'est
simplement
un coup d'p je fais confiance à la la
justice de de de mon pays. Vous
faites confiance à la justice du pays.
Je peux je peux je peux rien vous dire
d'autre. Euh oui, écoutez, je
je je je veux croire encore que que dans
ce pays, il y a des choses
il y a des choses qui marchent qui
marchent bien. Voilà. Euh laissez-moi
laissez-moi cet espoir. Euh et donc euh
voilà ce que je sais, je me satisfais
déjà que que le parquet de Paris n'est
pas classé sans suite. Euh il avait la
possibilité de le faire, il ne l'a pas
fait. C'est une première étape. Voilà.
Maintenant je c'est au Parquet national
financier de d'assurer la suite des
investigations.
Le financement de la campagne d'Emmanuel
Macron, on en a parlé un petit peu. Euh
vous avez des griefs avec notre
président. Vous pensez qu'il est il a il
a bien agi sur Alstom ? Pas bien agi ou
vous voulez vraiment le charger et aller
le chercher ?
Écoutez pour avoir euh
pour avoir décortiqué cette affaire et
et vraiment moi mon point d'entrée une
fois encore c'était dans quelles
conditions l'autorisation a été donnée.
Donc j'ai vraiment cherché cherché à
comprendre, j'ai décortiqué le truc dans
dans dans tous les sens. Ce qui est
apparu très clairement, c'est que euh
c'est que Arnaud Montebourg euh avait
été baladé dans cette affaire. C'estàd
que euh Arnaud Mondbourg, il a vraiment
appris euh euh la vente d'Alstom, euh
son caractère en tout cas définitif à
travers la la dépêche la dépêche
Bloomberg en avril en avril 2014. Il
avait eu une information avant, je sais
plus, pardon, c'est travaux de la
commission sont un peu loin maintenant.
Je sais plus si c'est en janvier ou
février à l'occasion d'un d'un voyage
euh de du président François Hollande
aux États-Unis. Il accompagne François
Hollande et à cette occasion, il croise
Caragema, présidente à ce moment-là de
de J France qui lui dit "Vous savez, Ji
pourrait s'intéresser à Alstom Power."
Il rentre,
c'était pardon, je sais plus si c'était
janvier ou février, je crois que c'était
début février. Il rentre, il rentre en
France et il dit "Convoquez-moi
Patricon, je veux savoir ce qui se passe
derrière derrière derrière ce que m'a
dit Clara Guemar." Il reçoit Patrick
Cron, je crois qu' temps tant que les
agendas se mettent en place, il le voit
fin mars, donc il ne tarde pas. Il le
voit fin mars et Patrick Cron lui dit
froidement dans les yeux dans les yeux
euh "Il y a aucun projet. Non non dorm
tranquille monsieur le ministre ne se
passe rien. Donc clairement Patrick Cron
se paye se paye sa figure. Moi ce qui
m'a toujours intrigué dès ce moment dès
ce dès ce moment-là. Moi je suis déjà
partie des
c'est la nonchalance des services de
renseignement économique, c'est ça ?
Non, pas pas que déjà ce qui m'a ce qui
m'a intrigué, on va y revenir
évidemment, mais je fais partie des des
députés des républicains, je sais pas
comment s'appelait à l'époque, ça
républicain ou l'UMP euh qui ont
vraiment soutenu
qui ont le temps avait déjà passé euh
qui avait qui a vraiment soutenu Arnaud
Monbourg dans dans cette affaire, qui a
applaudi à la à la la prise de son
décret. On nétait pas très nombreux, il
y avait Jacques Miard, quelques
quelques-uns. Voilà. euh sur euh à à à
le soutenir et et à ne pas considérer
que c'est une atteinte épouvantable euh
à la vie des affaires que de que de
prétendre donner un feu vert dans
certaines circonstances. Donc euh donc
voilà, je moi je crois je crois
Montebourg, il nous dit d'ailleurs en
2014 en séance en question d'actualité à
l'Assemblée nationale
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je fasse ?
Je vais pas interroger un détecteur de
mensonge, pardon, installer un détecteur
de mensonge dans mon bureau pour
interroger les patrons du du CAC 40.
Donc je pense, je crois vraiment que que
Caron Mondbourg dans saffaire a été
sincère. Mais ce qui m'a toujours
intrigué, c'est comment Patrick Cron a
pu mentir froidement à Arnaud Monbourg
en face de lui, sachant que pour
finaliser cette vente dont on sait
maintenant évidemment qu'il avait
commencé à en parler avant et que et que
effectivement Caragemar n'avait pas dit
n'importe quoi euh alors qu'il savait
normalement qu'il aurait besoin de la
signature d'Arnaud Monbourg pour faire
cette vente.
Peut-être qu'on allait changer de
ministre
et donc je sais pas si euh si les choses
étaient aussi précises que ça dans son
esprit. Mais en tout cas, j'avais dès le
départ, il me semblait que ça clochait
un peu comme histoire et qu'il avait
probablement eu une assurance à plus
haut niveau. Et donc plus haut niveau,
c'est assez logiquement. Et d'ailleurs,
ça n'a rien de choquant.
C'est quoi plus haut niveau ?
Vu les vu ce qui est l'état de plus haut
niveau, c'est la présidence, c'est la
présidence de la République. Donc il
voilà et donc j'ai évidemment cherché
pendant la la commission d'enquête à à
savoir comment ça s'était passé.
J'ai notamment
alors il y a il y a un élément factuel
quand même qui qui est assez perturbant
par rapport à cette belle histoire qu'on
nous a raconté de tout le monde est
censé avoir appris la vente d'alstom par
la dépêche Bloomberg en avril 2014. Bon
et notamment Emmanuel Macron quand il
devient ministre de l'économie
après le le limogage à l'été 2014 de de
de de d'Arna Monbourg. Euh assez peu de
temps après, il vient dev voir la
commission des des affaires économiques
de de l'Assemblée nationale et il
explique euh "Vous savez comment s'est
passé cette affaire, on a tous été mis
devant le fait accompli. Euh c'est par
l'agence Bouberg qu'on a appris ça. Euh
personne n
et la petite étude à 292,
personne n'était n'était au courant et
cetera et cetera. Or, il se trouve qu'on
a quand même découvert pendant pendant
les nos investigations que que quelqu'un
avait commandé à l'Agence de
participation de l'État dès
dès le mois de
novembre 2000
alors pardon, je dis pas de bêtises,
novembre 2012 novembre 2012 avait
commandé une étude via LAAPE
à Até Carnet.
un cabinet de de de conseil pour
examiner ce que seraient les
conséquences de du désengagement de
Buig, du changement d'actionnaire de
référence euh au sein d'Alstom, au sein
du groupe Alstom.
Euh alors ce cette commande est assez
étonnante puisque déjà elle aurait pas
dû être passée à la PE
puisque la PE l'État la PE gère le
portefeuille de de l'État actionnaire.
Or l'État n'était pas actionnaire d'
Stop. Bon,
la PE, c'est l'agence
l'agence pardon, l'agence des
participations de l'État. Donc, c'est
assez étonnant que la commande a été
passée à la PE. Notre patron était
monsieur Azema à l'époque. Bon euh ce
qu'il y a d'encore plus étonnant, c'est
que le le cabinet du ministre de
l'économie euh n'a pas souvenir,
Arnbourg, à qui j'ai écrit sur ce sujet,
n'a aucun souvenir euh même en
interrogeant ses collaborateurs de
l'époque, d'avoir passé cette commande à
la paix. et il m'a d'ailleurs répondu
mais moi si j'avais eu à poser des
questions à quelqu'un de réfléchir à
l'avenir des somag participation d'État
j'aurais posé la question parce que
l'agence participation d'État n'était
pas compétente la PE n'était pas
actionnaire donc ça est assez étrange.
Donc Mondbourg me dit "Non, c'est pas
moi qui ai commandé cette étude en
autour de l'automne 2000 2012." Donc
j'ai écrit au premier ministre de de
l'époque qui s'appelle Jean-Marcot euh
dans le cadre de la commission d'enquête
qui m'a répondu "Monsieur président de
la commission d'enquête, je découvre
cette histoire d'une étude. Moi, je n'ai
jamais rien commandé. Ça ne vient pas de
ça ne vient pas de de de mes services.
J'ai interrogé mon ancien conseiller
compétent. C'est pas nous qui l'avons
commandé. Alors donc c'est pas ministre
de l'économie, c'est pas le premier
ministre. Donc j'ai écris au secrétaire
général de de de la présidence de la
République de de de l'époque.
Mais
les mecs de la PE, ils vous ont pas dit
directement qui est-ce qui avait demandé
le la chose. Monsieur Azeman ne se
souvenait plus exactement si c'était
l'Élysée Matignon ou il ne se souvenait
plus. C'est pour ça que j'ai mené c'est
pour ça que j'ai mené l'enquête et le le
secrétaire général de la présidence de
la République me dit
"Non, j'ai jamais eu connaissance de
cette de cette étude, c'est pas moi non
plus. D'ailleurs, ça été assez
surprenant que que l'Élysée passe cette
commande. C'est un mtinignant de de le
faire ou au ministre mais nous
onintervenait pas en direct." Bon voilà
donc dans ce petit jeu de de déduction,
peut-être que j'ai l'esprit
mal orienté mais du coup je j'en ai
conclu que assez assez logiquement. euh
que c'était le monsieur affaire
économique de la présidence de la
République qui avait dû passer sa
commande. J'ai pas eu l'occasion de
vérifier puisque quand on préside une
commission d'enquête parlementaire, on a
un pouvoir de convocation. La seule
personne qu'on a pas le droit de
convoquer au nom de la séparation des
pouvoirs, c'est euh c'est le président
de la République, hein. Donc évidemment,
j'ai pas eu l'occasion de de
l'interroger, mais euh mon point de vue,
il y a aucun doute possible sur le fait
que euh c'est c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
a commandé cette étude à AT Carnet en
octobre 2012 pour savoir ce qui se
passerait dans l'hypothèse où Big
vendait ses participations.
Une fois encore cette cette étude
d'ailleurs, elle est quand même assez
elle est elle est assez précise.
C'est pas un truc fait à l'emportepièce
300000 € à peu près.
Étude qui coûte 300000 €. Bon, c'est
près de la journée consultant, c'est
c'est enfin c'est une belle étude.
Euh bon, j'observe d'ailleurs que
enfin que il est pas forcément euh il a
plutôt fait son boulot jusque-là
d'ailleurs de passer commande de cette
étude qui un peu étrange et qu'il n'est
pas informé le ministre le ministre de
l'économie qu'il soit passé directement
par le patron de de la PE mais euh
dans dans le système français euh voilà,
il y a des choses étranges.
Euh bon et en tout cas qu'il est qu'il
est cherché à se renseigner sur les
conséquences de de la vente d'alstom
potentiellement de général électrique
par plutôt d'un bon sentiment. Moi ce
qui me gêne c'est que en tout état de
cause, l'autorité qui a dépensé 300000 €
en octobre 2012 pour savoir si
qu'est-ce qui allait se passer si on
vendait si on vendait alstom
à quelqu'un, n'est pas profiter des 18
mois qui restent avant l'annonce de
officielle de ce deal pour pour trouver
une solution alternative. Ça veut dire
qu'à un moment, il y a eu effectivement
un feu vert
un kitus politique qui a été donné à
ceux qui qui avait ce deal ce deal en
projet.
Je vous ouvre une partie. Donc on est on
est complètement voilà une fois encore
dans ce dans ce process d'entre soi euh
c'estàd que la la voie normale des
choses aurait été que l'investisseur
général électrique
avec le vendeur Alstom aille voir le
ministre de l'économie
Ornbourg
dès qu'ils avaient ce projet de deal et
que le ministère de l'économie le bureau
en charge de ces questions là la
direction générale du trésor prenne le
temps d'examiner
patiemment tous les enjeux, c'est pas
comme ça que ça a marché.
Je vous ouvre une parenthèse.
Euh
on n pas des services qui sont censés un
peu veiller sur nos bijoux de famille.
On a on n pas des des gens voilà qui qui
s'interrogent par exemple quand on
commence à approcher les bijoux de
famille. surtout surtout notre
souveraineté nucléaire, notre
souveraineté militaire, notre
souveraineté notre parole diplomatique,
des choses comme ça. Donc est-ce que
vous avez enquêter sur le process
d'intelligence économique, de
renseignement économique, de protection
des avoirs français, de défense des
avoirs français ? Je vous parle même pas
de mesures proactives,
je vous parle des de gens censés veiller
au bon déroulement, notre business, de
nos acquis. Je vous donne un exemple.
Imaginez-vous, il me prend l'idée
d'aller acheter euh 50 kg de nitrate de
d'ammonium euh dans mon dans mon
restaurant du coin ou mon ma
quincaillerie du coin. Je suis sûr dans
les 48 heures, je vais avoir des gens
qui s'intéressent à mon euh mon
exploitation agricole.
Non pas parce que je suis agriculteur,
mais peut-être potentiellement parce que
ça peut créer des dégâts. Est-ce qu'il y
a le même type de de fonctionnaire qui
veille à ce type de dégâts ? Pas est-ce
que c'est quand même un dégât ? Il faut
appeler un chat un chat.
Je crois que vous avez eu l'occasion de
d'interroger de de meilleurs de vrais
spécialistes des de de de des questions
de renseignement et de renseignement.
Non non, là c'était que le début, vous
inquiétez pas. on va commencer vraiment
à sortir de notre chapeau des gens de
notre réseau qui s'intéressent à ce
genre de chos. Là, c'était que la
péritement. Alors, on a évidemment
cherché effectivement à comprendre
puisque ce
discours officiel, on a appris ça par
l'agence Bloomberg effectivement nous
assourir notamment il y a quand même un
fait qui objectivement aurait dû aurait
dû quand même alerter dont j'espère qu'
qu'il a qu'il a alerté quelqu'un, c'est
c'est l'arrestation de Frédéric Pirocci.
Comment
vous avez rencontré d'ailleurs en prison
aux États-Unis ? Vous êtes le seul ?
Non.
Euh avec une collègue de la commission
d'enquête, Natalia Poussiref oui lui
rendre visite dans sa dans sa prison aux
États-Unis. Mais
il y avait les côtes cassées à l'époque
ou pas du tout ?
Comment ? Euh
parce qu'il s'est fait tabasser quand
même là-bas.
Euh oui, je crois que malheureusement il
enfin il a eu l'occasion d'écrire
décrire son expérience.
Le le qu d'ors l'a protégé pas du tout.
l' laissé complètement hein.
Alors moi moi je vais rendre hommage aux
autorités consulaires françaises.
C'est des petites mes locales.
Voilà les petites ou
consul de France à consulte général à
New York à Washington c'est déjà pas mal
c'est un peu plus que des petites mains.
Mais à ce niveau-là il y a eu d'ailleurs
c'est là que c'est que le système est
c'est là que c'est impardonnable.
C'est-à-dire que quand il est arrêté aux
États-Unis, euh il est pris en charge
par le consul général de France euh à
New York euh qui qui qui établit en
contact. Enfin, il raconte il raconte ça
dans son dans dans son dans son livre,
hein. Euh et je sais qu'à euh et après
quand il a été dans son 2è séjour, le
consul général de France à Washington a
été qui m'a permis d'ailleurs de de
d'aller lui rendre visite euh en prenant
sur lui d'organiser une visite
consulaire et de pas dire qu'on é dans
le cadre d'une commission d'enquête a
été voilà, on été des gens très très
très impliqués. Euh là où là où en
revanche euh enfin ça ça dysfonctionne,
c'est que comment imaginer effectivement
que notre consulaire aux États-Unis sont
au courant de l'arrestation d'un
vice-président d'une filiale euh
mondiale euh d'Alstom. Pas n'importe
quoi. En plus, il est euh une filiale
qui fait les chaudières euh qui est dans
le nucléaire quoi, vraiment euh
et qui ne se passe rien en France et
qu'on n'en tire aucune conclusion, aucun
intérêt en France. Euh, imaginons
l'inverse, un un vice-président de de J
le présons, par exemple le président de
Ji France met en examen. J'imagine que
les Américains sont immédiatement au
courant de ce qui se passe. Bon euh
en France, on n'est pas le même niveau
de gravité, il y a pas d'arrestation
mais là, il y a une arrestation d'un
vice-président d'Alstom et visiblement,
il ne se passe rien en France. Alors, on
a essayé de d'essayer d'en savoir plus.
le la la déléguée à l'intelligence
économique à l'époque
pardon j'ai pas était tellement
inoubliable qu'on a
j'ai
pas charitable euh
il y a pas de charité à avoir quand on
commence
en fin de journée on en échappe.
non c'était une femme en plus je crois
de de bonne volonté mais malheureusement
la la la l'intelligence économique en
France a été très longtemps baladé dans
des espèces de guerre d'influence une
fois rattachée au premier ministre le
temps de de délier ça comment ça elle a
été baladé l'intelligence économique en
France
pardon
pourquoi elle a été baladée
l'intelligence économique en France en
réalité je pense que personne n'a
vraiment envie qu'on fasse de
l'intelligence économique.
Qui personne ? Alors personne c'est
c'est ni la DGSE qui a envie de garder
son son précarré, qui a envie de garder
tout le renseignement euh y compris le
renseignement économique avec les
défauts qu' le fonctionnement de la
DGSE, je vais je vais revenir et
certainement pas euh Bersi qui a pas
forcément envie de voir un certain
nombre de de de veilles lui échapper ou
de trop de gens mettent leur nez dans
des dans des affaires qui ne faut encore
aussi une espèce de de chasse réservée
de de Bercil. Et là et là ce que je
sous-entends c'est c'est la question une
fois encore des du mélange des genres de
l'entre soi et et des influence qu'on
laisse volontiers s'exercer. On veut
évidemment pas que que des éléments
extérieurs viennent mettre leur nez dans
dans tout ça. Donc du coup
l'intelligence économique a été souvent
dans notre pays tourné en dérision.
D'ailleurs, c'est assez intéressant de
voir à quel point on a tendance à moquer
l'économie de l'intelligence. C'est ça.
Voilà. à à moquer ce travail
d'intelligence économique, à le à à à à
riconner un peu dessus. Euh sont
forcément des gens complotistes, des
gens pas très sérieux, pas très
professionnels qui qui font ça et euh
euh
façon de les discréditer pour éviter
qu'il mettent leur nez partout.
Oui, bien sûr, bien sûr. Et donc euh
donc la France n'a jamais eu de
d'organisation stable et donc avec un
service alors qui est de temps en temps
balloté. Vous avez eu à certaines
époques des des des gens qui sont
intéressés un peu un peu au sujet
comme qui
ah ben là encore je je vais pas avoir
l'air de de faire systématiquement
référence à Nicolas Sarkozi mais je
pense que la nomination d'un garçon
comme comme monsieur Juet comme Juillet
sur les sujets d'intelligence économique
pas resté longtemps il est resté un an
puis après il plutôt la volonté quand
même de de prendre le sujet un peu
relativement relativement au sérieux euh
voilà en tout
force de constater que les services
d'intelligence économique ont été
baladés régulièrement une fois près du
premier ministre une fois ber ou une
fois de nouveau retour au pr du
premistre et cetera.
Bien bref, au moment de l'affaire
Alstom, la déléguée d'intelligence
économique est au courant de rien, ne
voit rien. Euh lorsqu'elle a vaguement
une info, elle fait une elle fait une
note quand même euh à euh à Matignon, il
se passe rien. Voilà. Côté côté des GSE,
euh
vous les avez interrogé, convoqué.
Oui, c'est la seule personne qui qui
n'est pas répondu
à une convocation, c'est le patron.
C'est le patron de la DGSE
qui s'appelait
C'est Bernard Bajolet à l'époque. Non
non, c'éit pas lui.
Non non non, c'est plus Bernard Bajolet.
C'est c'est peut-être même l'actuel
l'actuel patron de DGSE. Euh alors c'est
vrai qu'on
on était peut-être un peu pris par des
questions de délai parce qu'on était
dans les dans les derniers les dernières
semaines de de la commission d'enquête.
Je veux bien croire qu'il a un agenda un
peu compliqué. Enfin, le fait est que la
seule personne qui a refusé euh de de de
répondre à une convocation avec qui il
n'a pas été possible de fixer une date,
c'est le patron de la DGSE qui du coup
nous a envoyé son adjoint, monsieur un
autre diplomate
qui très diplomatiquement nous a répondu
que que toutes les questions qu'on lui
posait étaient couvertes par le secret
défense et donc qui ne répondrait qui ne
pourrait répondre répondre à rien.
Nicolas qui a prolongé le secret
quand bien même nous le je sais pas
votre question dépasse la sphère de de
connaissance mais en tout cas euh
en tout cas on était
euh voilà on on a eu même à H clos même
à H clos on n pas eu de pas eu la
moindre réponse sur de la part de la DGS
vous en tant que parlementaire vous
n'étiez pas accrédité pour recevoir ce
secret défense
non c'est un des dysfonctionnements
d'ailleurs d'une commission d'enquête
alors
c'est que les les président de
commission d'enquête ne sont pas
habilités. Alors, il pourrait l'être. Ça
supposerait que le que l'exécutif
accepte. Bon, il est pas forcément très
très partageur. Euh voilà, nous-même on
aurait pu demander une enfin écrire au
premier ministre pour obtenir une levée
du secret défense sur certains points.
Le le le délai une fois encore une
commission d'enquête ne permet pas une
commission d'enquête. Elle doit elle n'a
pas le droit de siéger plus de plus de 6
mois. Euh une mesure salutaire en
souvenir du comité de salut publique.
Euh faut pas que les les pouvoirs un peu
exorbitants dont dispose une commission
d'enquête parlementaire qui est quand
même le niveau de contrôle le le maximum
du du parlement. Il y a aucun pouvoir de
sanction
aille aille trop dans la s de de
sanction si les gens ne pas
ou effectivement ment ment serment.
C'est pas des combiens fantoches c'est
pour amuser la galerie.
Non c'est assez intéressant. C'est c'est
quand même ce ce témoignage sous sermon
est quand même assez intéressant.
Il y a d'autres il y a deux la
DGSE vous a enfumé quand même.
Je me souviens. Pardon.
La DGSE vous a enfumé.
Ils ont pas enfumé. Ils ont carrément
dit on vous répondra pas quoi. Donc on
peut pas vous répondre secret défense.
Donc euh pour revenir au
pour pour revenir au à votre question
précédente sur la la valeur de ce de ce
pouvoir de convocation et de témoignage
sur ce serment, c'est quand même
intéressant. Moi, il y a il y a une ou
deux personnes à qui j'ai posé des
questions euh qui étaient justement un
petit peu un petit peu un petit peu
sensible sur à quel moment vous avez
vous avez décidé euh vous avez décidé de
Je souviens une question par exemple
à Martin Big en lui demandant si ce
qu'on écrit certains journalistes sur
lesquels en fait il avait il avait
commencé à avoir des contacts avec
Général électrique dès dès 2000 dès la
fin 2012
évidemment. donc euh loin de l'histoire
officielle euh était vrai. Euh
en fait, il meur
il me répond "Oh, je suis passé là, je
peux pas croire tout ce qu' a dit tout
ce que tout ce qu' ont pu écrire les
journalistes.
J'ai passé l'âge de croire tout ce qu'on
écrit les journalistes. Tout ce qu'
écrivent les journalistes. Euh voilà,
avec une dénégation de la tête. Voilà,
moi j'observe qu'il ne m'a pas dit non
en réalité, mais ça j'en découvert en
lisant le procès verbal. Euh après donc
quand on est dans des zones où les gens
sont euh peu embarrassés pour euh pour
pour vous répondre, euh on on a quand
même à ce moment-là une attitude un
petit peu différente où on voit que les
gens font attention euh à ce qu'ils
disent pour euh faire attention de ne
pas mentir.
Revenons à nos petits services.
Donc euh donc c'est quand même
intéressant ce secret.
Revenons à nos petits services
alors sur sur nos services de sur sur la
DGSE. Donc voilà, moi je je garde
évidemment l'espoir, le secret espoir là
encore, c'est c'est cette même
candur qui qui me fait avoir espoir en
la justice de bon pays. J'espère que que
la DGSE a quand même perçu quelques
signaux faibles. Vous savez qu'en fait
les enquêtes de du du DOJ, du
département d'État sur les faits de
corruption chez Hstom datait pas de
c'est pas des négociations qui se sont
réglées après la vente d'Alstom comme
l'a dit comme l'a dit Patrick Cron.
C'est en réalité des enquêtes qui ont
commencé dès 2010 20112
qui ont été ouvertes bien longtemps bien
longtemps avant. Donc j'espère que que
la DGSE
a recueilli bien avant des éléments et
qu'elle a fait des signements. Le
problème de la DGSE c'est qu'elle
travaille totalement en silo.
Donc en clair, elle fait remonter de
l'information au ministre de la défense
qui en l'occurrence était pas
particulièrement compétent. enfin a pu
tirer euh ou pas euh euh l'alarme
évidemment sur les enjeux en terme de en
terme de défense et après elle faire
monter euh la formation à la présidence
de la République. Donc là encore si la
présence de la République avait de toute
façon décidé que qu'il fallait faire, on
peut comprendre que les alartes de la
DGSE, dans l'hypothèse, j'en aurais eu,
ce qui est mon secret espoir, euh n'est
pas produit des faits des faits
escomptés. Donc on a en conclusion, on a
quand même un vrai dysfonctionnement là
aussi de du dispositif d'alerte de
d'alerte de l'État euh qui concerne
aussi d'ailleurs le ministère de le
ministère de la justice. Comment
imaginer qu'un citoyen français euh
vice-président d'une entreprise aussi
stratégique que ce soit arrêté aux
États-Unis sur les affaires de
corruption et que le ministère de la
justice ne se mette pas un tout petit
peu plus en branle que ça quoi ? Euh bon
là aussi malheureusement dans les 6 mois
on ne peut pas on peut pas tout régler
et donc on n pas réussi on a on n pas
réussi à éclaircir davantage les choses
avec le bureau le bureau d'entraide
international mais c'est aussi un vrai
sujet.
Une petite question d'internet que je je
prends la volée. Pourquoi la rédaction
du rapport de la commission Alstom
a-t-elle été confiée à un macronisme
purju Guillaume Casbarian qui en a
conclu qu'il n'y avait rien à voir ?
Voilà. Alors ça c'est la règle de
fonctionnement des des commissions
d'enquête dans notamment qui relève du
droit de tirage de de de l'opposition
depuis 2008 depuis la révision consciale
de 2008. L'oppos les groupes
d'opposition ont une fois par an un
droit de tirage pour obtenir la création
d'une commission d'enquête. Mais dans ce
cas-là, il doit y avoir un partage des
fonctions de président de la commission
d'enquête et de rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête. À l'époque,
c'était le groupe majoritaire d'ailleurs
qui choisissait. Donc c'est le groupe
majoritaire qui a choisi d'avoir la
fonction de rapporteur notamment parce
que en général pour les technos tenir la
plume c'est c'est le plus important. Ça
m'a arrangé qu' qui qu' qui qu'il qui
fasse ce choix parce que bon euh
moi ce qui m'intéressait c'était plutôt
le de choisir l'ordre du jour de de nos
travaux et le pouvoir de convocation
dont dispose le président. Et voilà
pourquoi il y a ce partage des rôles.
Donc évidemment, il y a une petite
dissonance de lecture entre
l'avant-propos que j'ai pu rédiger et
l'analyse faite par mon collègue
Guillaume Casbarian. Euh à ceci prêx, ce
qui assez intéressant, c'est que même là
où Guillaume Casbarian dit euh circuler,
il y a rien à voir, il y a pas de
problème. Euh en revanche euh il a quand
même été d'accord avec moi pour euh pour
apporter les mêmes solutions. Euh
c'est-à-dire là où il dit euh euh là où
moi je vois des jeux d'influence autour
de la de la de la vente d'Alstom
notamment de de enfin sur la façon dont
dont l'autorisation investissement
étranger en France est donnée, sur la
façon dont elle est pas contrôlée par le
Parlement. J'observe qu'il a qu'il a
repris euh mes propositions euh à son
compte et que notamment nous avons tous
conclu au sein de cette commission
d'enquête euh qu'à l'avenir il fallait
du contrôle parlementaire sur la façon
dont travaillait Bercy euh et qu'il
fallait renforcer ce dispositif de
contrôle de ce dispositif
d'autorisation. C'est du wish full
sinking ça non ?
Pardon ?
C'est des incantations.
Alors euh à ce stade le résultat n'est
pas n'est pas totalement performant mais
on a quand même énormément progressé
depuis la depuis la commission
d'enquête. Vous faites partie du néant
un peu plus que rien.
Oui. Alors on était clairement dans le
néant. Bon on était clairement dans le
néant. C'estàd qu'en clair la la
procédure IF elle était totalement elle
était totalement bidon. Euh et Merci
refusait de communiquer sur quoi que ce
soit. J'avais même posé je crois 2 ans
avant une question écrite pour savoir
combien il y avait de dossiers instruits
par Ber au titre des autorisations
investissement étrangers en France.
Réponse du ministre de l'économie de
l'époque qu'il était Emmanuel Macron.
C'est comme ces ces décisions sont
motivées par souvent par le secret
défense des décisions de protection et
bien on peut pas vous donner les
statistiques. C'est magnifique. Bon donc
on a quand même obtenu depuis notamment
dans la loi Pact grâce à la commission
d'enquête. C'était une des
préconisations que nous faisions qui a
un certain nombre de de au moins de de
décisions qui soient rendu public. Donc
on a un rapport annuel. On a obtenu dans
la pacte il y a un début de contrôle
parlementaire. Là on a un petit
problème, c'est que le Sénat s'est un
peu fait enfumer par Berti et ils ont
acheté un dispositif qui ne qui ne roule
pas, qui ne vole pas. Euh bon, puisqueen
fait aujourd'hui, il ne pourra y avoir
de contrôle parlementaire un peu
approfondi que lorsque les dossiers
seront clos. Mais en réalité, certains
dossiers seront jamais clos. Euh, je
prends la vente par exemple d'Alcatel et
de la filiale Alcatel Submarine Networks
qui est les câbles les câbles
sous-marins. Vous savez que ASN, boîte
qui était française, était une filiale
d'Alcatel, héberge aujourd'hui 80 %
enfin fait transiter 80 % de de
l'internet mondial. une boîte française
qui détient ça. Bon, évidemment euh ces
terminaux ou MCAB sont des éléments euh
à protéger puisque si vous brancher d'un
bout à l'autre, vous pouvez euh
découvrir beaucoup de choses. Bon, alors
évidemment bah lors de la vente
d'Alcatel à Nokia, qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait ? Bah, on a dit euh bon bah ils
auront pas le droit, Nokia devra
respecter un peu de secret défense.
Donc, il n'aura pas le droit de d'aller
mettre son là. il n'ur pas de savoir ça.
Il faudra ta habiliter secret défense.
Le patron devrait être nommé d'un commun
accord avec avec nous et cetera. Bon euh
mais c'est c'est c'est c'est le c'est le
seul niveau de de protection que qu'on
sait euh euh
qu' qu'on sait mettre. Enfin voilà euh
pardon.
B voilà. Hop hop hop.
Alors oui non pardon pardon pardon.
Et donc oui, j'avais perdu le fil de ma
pensée, j'y reviens. Donc ces mesures de
protection qui ont été mises sur ASN,
elles dureront aussi longtemps que Nokia
restera actionnaire de de d'N. Donc en
fait si on lit la loi, ce qui vient
d'être voté dans la loi pacte, c'est
effectivement assez inopérant. On est
bien d'accord. Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que les sénateurs se sont rendus
compte qu'ils se sont fait euh flouer.
Donc, j'ai bon espoir qu'on en revienne
à la première occasion, notamment s'il y
a un texte qui vient sur la la sécurité
euh économique dans prolongement du
rapport de Raphaël Govin. On pourra
pourra y revenir. Euh c'est la fameuse
loi de blocage, c'estàd qu'est-ce qu'on
accepte de communiquer comme information
à un pays étranger.
Je je pense qu'on qu'on arrivera à
améliorer le dispositif, mais voyez, on
a quand même créé au moins le principe,
c'est déjà quelque chose d'un contrôle
parlementaire sur ces procédures. C'est
c'était vraiment important. C'était une
ça justifie leur salaire quoi.
Des parlementaires voulaient dire ouais
non pour l'instant ça le justifie pas je
sûr parce que parce que effectivement
les pouvoirs sont un peu sont encore
assez vides. En tout cas, on a quand
même reconnu ce principe que il fallait
mettre du contrôle parlementaire. Une
fois encore, il est assez inopérant. Euh
bon, encore que un certain nombre, le
président des commissions des finances,
le rapporteur général de la commission
des finances ont déjà un pouvoir et donc
je pense qu'ils peuvent commencer à
mettre un peu plus le nez dans
quelques-uns de quelun de dossiers. Mais
enfin malgré tout, il y a un avant cette
commission d'enquête et il y a un après.
On vient de parler par exemple,
c'est pour votre ego ça. Non
non non, je pense de demander à tous les
acteurs, demander même à à Ber sont
obligés de reconnaître que oui, il faut
le le décret par exemple sur le enfin
tout le décret sur les secteurs
stratégiques a été a été revu depuis
même la partie législative a été a été
complètement complètement réécrite. On a
enfin
on a mis en évidence le fait que le
régime de sanction dans l'hypothèse où
quelqu'un oublierait de demander à
l'autorisation pour acheter une boîte
française. Ce qui s'est passé il y a pas
il y a pas très longtemps avec une boîte
gratuité.
Non. Alors à l'époque on avait quand
même on avait quand même une amende qui
disait jusqu'à deux fois le montant de
l'investissement. Au clair, vous prenez
Alstom 12 milliards 5 thorie amende
jusqu'à 25 milliards. Bon euh je vous
rassure, le truc était tellement mal
rédigé qu'on ne savait pas ce poids
d'amende s'appliquait aux gens qui
oubliaent de faire la demande de
l'autorisation d'investissement ou aux
gens qui ne tenaient pas les engagements
pris. Bon non mais c'est parce que c'est
un très vieux droit et ça date grosso
modo de 66 et que surtout comme on l'a
jamais appliqué depuis 1966 ce pouvoir
d'amende euh et bien euh on ne savait
même pas le le le faire le faire
marcher. Dans l'hypothèse, on aurait
voulu. et prison un peu non avec
pardon
de la prison avec
non je crois pas sur ces sujets-là il y
a pas de il y a pas de peine de prison
mais on est sur des peines d'amende qui
je pense pour le monde des affaires sont
sont suffisamment du donc ce dispositif
là il vient quand même de à la suite de
la commission d'enquête dans la loi pact
il a été totalement réécrit et
aujourd'hui du coup il est beaucoup plus
crédible avant il faisait rire les
avocats en clair aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il est fait plus rire parce qu'ils
ont bien compris qu'il y avait quand
même un dispositif qui qui pouvait
fonctionner encore faut-il vous me
direz-vous qu'il y a un peu de volonté
politique pour l'appliquer
encore l'espoir, c'est ça,
on est bien d'accord.
Bah, ça c'est le boulot du politique.
Alors effectivement, tant qu' tant qu'on
éra gouvernements qui fera le choix
d'élélire des gouvernements qui n'en ont
rien à faire et qui pensent que il faut
faire circuler l'argent, que il n'y a
pas de plus d'industrie française, qu'il
y a de culture française, on continuera
peut-être ne pas faire grand-chose, mais
demain, si un gouvernement veut faire
quelque chose, il en a les moyens. Bon
euh euh juste une petite question de
d'Internet. L'intelligence s'est fait
promener.
N'est-elle pas ne s'est-elle fait pas
mettre en laiss entre parenthèses par
des puissances extérieures ?
Pardon ? Là
la l'intelligence s'est fait promener.
On parlait d'intelligence économique.
Ouais.
Est-ce que elle s'est pas fait promener
? Elle s'est fait juste mettre en
laisse.
Non mais il faut il Non, on va appeler
un chat un chat.
nos centrales nucléaires, nos
portavions, nos TGV, nos barrages
hydrauliques sont en train de se faire
dépesser.
Dépesser.
Vous êtes d'accord avec moi ? On est en
train de se faire éventrer en place
publique et découper et revendu
tranquillement
selon le le titre d'un ouvrage de de
Laurent Izard là, c'est la France. La
France a la découpe. Oui.
D'accord. Donc là, on se fait découper,
c'est bien joli. Il y a il y a des gens
qui prennent de l'argent. Bon, est-ce
que vous avez interrogé les militaires
parce que le militaire vous lui
expliquez que bon sa gâchette, elle
vient d'être privatisée, il va pas
pouvoir tirer si les trois puissances
derrière lui donnent pas l'autorisation.
À mon avis, il convulse. Là, c'est ce
qui s'est passé avec notre Charles de
Gaulle là. Non, c'est c'est on vient de
se faire et passez-moi l'expression, je
vais être un peu trivial. On vient de se
faire couper les couilles là.
Oui, très clair. C'est euh
alors les militaires, on a interrogé un
certain nombre de militaires mais plutôt
des gens qui nous qui nous éclairent sur
la façon dont c'était dont tout ça
fonctionné, pas sur pas forcément sur
les sur les conséquences qu'en réalité
qu'en réalité chacun chacun connaît.
Notamment pour aller un peu plus loin
même que ce que vous dites. On est euh
vous savez que les Américains ont un
régime d'autorisation effectivement sur
l'utilisation de des des matériaux euh
ce qu'on appelle la législation ITAR euh
qui s'applique par exemple à d'assaut
quand ils vendent un rafale en Égypte.
S'il y a un missile dedans qui a un
composant américain, et bien les
Américains sont en droit de Bon euh donc
oui, le le problème très clairement
c'est que aujourd'hui nos sous-marins
lorsqu'ils embarquent des engins de
propulsion des turbines euh des turbines
Alstom, ils ne sont plusarfis. Euh on
est bien d'accord. Euh donc oui, la
perte de souveraineté, elle est
Donc les militaires, ils ont dit quoi ?
Euh bah là-dessus, on avait interrogé
euh bah je là-dessus, ils n'ont plus
qu'àissé au fait que qu'il y avait un
petit un petit enjeu effectivement de
d'indépendance. Oui, on est bien
d'accord.
C'est c'est c'est tout.
Non, je je pas pas rentrer dans le
détail puisque on est sur des auditions
qui pour certaines sont couvertes par
par le par le secret. Certaines
auditions ont lieu à H clos et donc je
n'ai pas le droit d'en révéler la
teneur.
Compéter des câbles un petit peu. Non,
pardon. dans dans le 8 kg, il y en a qui
sont montés au plafond quand même. Non,
il
Non, parce que une fois encore, on n pas
on a on n pas forcément cherché à à
rentrer euh notre notre porte d'entrée.
C'était la façon dont dont l'État
prenait ses décisions euh sur les
ventes. Donc, on a vu clairement qu'il y
avait pas une anticipation formidable.
Et l'audition du du ministre de la
défense, de l'ancien ministre de la
défense aussi. D'ailleurs, monsieur
Drillant a permis de permis de
comprendre que oui, le le le alors cela
dit, j'aurais quand même j'ai j'ai dit
tout à l'heure que à Ber se passait pas
grand-chose dans cette procédure
d'autorisation des investissements
étrangers en France. Je voudrais je
voudrais pardon rendre quand même rendre
hommage quand même à la à la DGA,
c'està-dire que le seul secteur où il se
passe quelque chose quand même sur les
secteurs DGA qui est
dans les secteurs la direction générale
de de l'armement euh la DGA elle elle a
une connaissance extrêmement approfondie
quand même de nos entreprises qui ont un
intérêt stratégique pour eux en matière
de matière de défense
parce que c'est parce que ce sont des
des entreprises notamment qui
connaissent parce qu'on a aussi un
régime de de de de licence à
l'exportation
notamment sur des biens double usage.
Donc ils ont une connaissance
extrêmement fine, extrêmement précise de
de l'industrie de l'industrie française.
Vous les avez senti patriotes
et donc pardon
vous les avez senti patriotes un peu ?
Oui oui, je j'ai pas de doute j'ai pas
de doute là-dessus. à la fois sur à la
fois sur leur état d'esprit qui est
clairement euh défendre des éléments
indispensables à notre souveraineté euh
et faire leur travail avec une grande
rigueur. Et très clairement, ma
conviction c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans
notre dispositif de contrôle des
investissements étrangers en France, de
rachat d'entreprise française
stratégique, il ne se passe quelque
chose que à chaque fois que la DGA
s'emmêle, à chaque fois que la DGA tire
la sonnette d'alarme. Ça a été le cas
par exemple, je parlais de d'Alcatel
Submarine Network, c'est c'est le
ministère de la défense qui a tiré la
scène d'alarme dans les lettres
d'engagement qui ont été prises par
Général Ele électrique sur sur
le le rachat d' Stom Power, les seuls
engagements qu'on a demandé sont de
toute évidence ceux que la DGA a
identifié de son point de vue comme
étant comme étant stratégique.
On va parler un peu d'Europe.
Vous êtes monté jusqu'à Bruxelles pour
parler de ce petit dossier et puis dans
une de vos vidéos, sans éventrer un
secret des dieux, vous dites voilà même
le le mec de chez LREM qui était dans
notre équipe a dit heureusement que les
gens ne se rendent pas compte de ce qui
se passe parce que sinon
ça fera on a on a eu
Qu'est-ce qu'il a dit exactement ?
On a eu une on est allé rencontrer le
le monsieur prospective
de la de la DG de la DG concurrence et
à Bruxelles
à Bruxelles pardon la direction générale
de la concurrence c'est la DG DG
concurrence c'est quand même c'est la
race des seigneurs à Bruxelles hein
c'est vraiment le c'est la plus
importante.
Ça touche combien un mec comme ça là-bas
?
Oh je je je préfère pas savoir
combien combien vous touchez vous ? Un
député gagne à peu près euh 5000 5000 €
net. Euhz
à peu près parce que parce que depuis le
prélèvement à la source euh ça
vous avez renoncé au cumul des mandats
d'ailleurs ?
Euh oui, plutôt malgré moi d'ailleurs.
Enfin, je suis resté conseiller
municipal donc c'est le c'est un mandat
qui est qui est gratuit. Un conseil
régional est rémunéré. Moi je je je n'ai
que mon indemnité de de de députés. Donc
c'est un peu plus de 5000 € 5700 € pour
être très précis. Donc un le le le grand
visionnaire, le monsieur prospectif de
la DG concurrence à Bruxelles,
j'ose pas comp non, très très
clairement, on lui a euh évidemment on a
interrogé sur la façon don dont tu as
regardé tout ça puis depuis Bruxelles
notamment au moment de la le projet de
fusion d'Alstom
d'Alstom transport pardon avec Smain. la
vente la vente du TGV. Là aussi quand
même le renoncement à comme dans le
nucléaire à 60 ans de de de recherche
publique de de commande publique hein.
Donc c'était pas l'entre que
l'entreprise de monsieur Cron Tom, c'est
une entreprise qui avait été
c'est la nôtre
qui était c'est c'est ce que dans notre
droit on appelle d'ailleurs le
patrimoine le patrimoine économique de
la nation. Voilà.
et que normalement le ministre de la
défense, le premier ministre sont censés
sont censés ils sont censés être les les
gardiens. C'est endroit on a on a un peu
perdu perdu cette notion. C'est-à-dire
voyez le par exemple je reviens à Stom
Power un instant pardon de de faire des
des allers-retours mais sur Alston Power
par exemple, il faut savoir que le le
magnifique bâtiment où on construit les
turbines Arabelles, la turbine arabelle
c'est ça fait la taille d'un Airbus.
C'est pas une petite turbine quoi. C'est
la taille d'un arbus. C'est un truc qui
fait plus de 300 m de long. Euh, elle
est construite dans une dans une usine
qui en fait est une usine qui avait été
construite d'abord au Bourget, un
bâtiment qui avait été construit au
bourget par le commissariat atomique,
c'est directement sur des fonds publics
et qui a été déménagé, réinstallé euh
réinstallé à à Bfort. Donc, on est on
est vraiment enfin ça montre à quel
point ce bâtiment il illustre, il
témoigne du fait que c'est une aventure
nationale en qui doit beaucoup au fond
au fond public sur la recherche et une
fois encore sur la commande sur la
commande publique. Bref, pour revenir à
à notre brave technocrate Bruxellois, on
lui a dit "Mais attendez vous pour les
entreprises françaises, vous enfin
comment vous procédez ?" Dire "Bah nous,
c'est très simple, pour nous il n'y a
que des acteurs sur le marché européen.
Euh il n'y a que des acteurs, il n'y a
pas de il n'y a pas d'investisseur
français, européens ou étrangers. Il n'y
a que des acteurs et tous les acteurs
sont au même niveau." Bien d'accord.
Mais alors euh en Europe, vous
interdisez par exemple les euh ser que
sur le respect de vos propres règles du
marché de la concurrence pure et
parfaite euh sur le marché intérieur,
vous interdisez les aides d'état. Euh
avec les Chinois, vous faites comment
puisqueils ne publient pas ils ne
publient pas leur compte. Donc vous ne
savez pas s'ils ont ou pas des aides
d'état ? Bravo ! Il me répondu. Ah oui,
c'est un problème. C'est pour ça que
nous négoions, m'a-t-il dit, un traité
Union européenne Chine.
Pour la petite histoire, il négocie, je
crois, depuis 6 ou 7 ans et je pense que
les Chinois les feront entraîner encore
quelques quelques quelques années. Donc
c'est assez effrayant effectivement ce
niveau de ce niveau de de naïveté.
C'estàd que on applique une fois encore,
c'est le meilleur hein, c'est le c'est
le monsieur chargé de la de la
prospective. Euh donc la la vision euh à
terme. Donc on applique euh pour
l'Europe, pour les entreprises, des
règles très strictes qu'on n'applique
pas à nos euh euh aux Chinois lorsqu'ils
viennent investir en France. On est
incapable de savoir euh s'ils ne sont
pas gavés d'État en général. D'ailleurs,
euh d'ailleurs ils le sont et là la
brosselle se crève. Al c'est très
intéressant de voir
que la Commission européenne a réagi au
moment de titre personnel, je dis je dis
plutôt tant mieux parce que j'étais je
pense que ce projet n'était pas n'était
pas indispensable. la fusion euh Alstom
ferroviaire et et et siince. Mais ce qui
est d'usant, c'est qu'on a pas entendu
la Commission européenne au moment de la
fusion des deux géants des deux géants
chinois du ferroviaire euh alors qu'elle
aurait très bien pu mettre son nez
dedans. Elle aurait même dû mettre son
nez dedans et leur dire mais attendez là
vous allez prendre une position qui sera
plus que dominante. Donc si vous faites
ça, OK vous de le faire mais vous ne
viendrez pas sur le marché européen.
Voilà, je me souviens pas que la
Commission européenne est et a eu le le
moindre le moindre battement de paupière
à l'époque. Oui, il y a un petit sujet
euh naïveté euh naïfeté européenne.
Donc donc en sortant euh votre collègue
de la République en marche dit
"Heureusement que les gens euh Donc je
reprends".
Oui. Oui.
Qu'est-ce qu'il a dit ?
Ah, c'était un échange très privé donc
je vais pas trahir cet échange privé.
Mais euh oui, en sortant de là, on s'est
regardé quand même et euh et
si les gens savaient
et je crois qu'on a on a partagé non, je
je pas je suis pas son porte-parole,
donc je vais pas du tout trahir trahir
ça pensée mais euh non, je pense pouvoir
dire qu'effectivement, on a quand même
partagé un niveau de de stupéfaction.
Bon, alors peut-être qu'on était pas
bien tombé, qu'en réalité euh monsieur
chargé de la la prospective à la DG
concurrence n'est pas l'esprit n'est pas
l'esprit le plus le plus éclairé sur sur
ces sujets-là. Euh je pense quand même
qu'il faut souligner qu'il commence à y
avoir un petit frémissement de prise de
conscience quand même à l'Union au sein
de la Commission européenne de
l'administration bruxelloise plus
exactement que les choses ne peuvent pas
euh fonctionner comme ça. On a un peu
progressé par exemple avec désormais
à l'initiative de de de la France quand
même le souligner de la France, de
l'Allemagne et de l'Italie d'un
dispositif désormais de de filtrage au
niveau au niveau européen de de mise en
commun
des de nos dispositifs de contrôle des
investissements étrangers. un dispositif
d'où c'est un règlement donc qui a pris
la qui a été pris initiative de la
dernière commission la précédente
commission qui oblige les pays à
échanger leurs information euh lorsqu'il
y a un rachat d'une entreprise dans un
secteur jugé stratégique dans un des
pays de de l'Union européenne. Est-ce
que c'est pas devenu une espèce d'usine
à gaz qui est devenue complètement
contre-productive qui qui ouvre la
France
à toute la concurrence desloyales de
certaines puissances qui se sont mis en
ordre de marche dans le les chiquier de
guerre économique ?
Non mais bien sûr que l'Europe l'Europe
est un peu tout ça et que bien bien sûr
il faut qu'elle évolue. Euh
non mais d'accord tout le monde veut
changer l'Europe. Ça fait 25 ans tout le
monde veut changer làdessus. Je suis je
suis sorti de ma naïveté et oui, je me
réjoui que tout le monde fait au moins à
peu près ce ce même constat.
On sort de l'Europe ou pas ?
Donc
le Brexit, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
?
Non, non, non, moi je je je suis
fondamentalement européen en ce sens que
je crois je crois quand même qu'on a
besoin qu'on a besoin de l'Europe à
condition que ce soit l'Europe puissance
qu'on nous a vendu. C'estàd que
croire en terme de religion, en terme de
quoi là ?
Euh
dire moi je sais je crois pas au
localisme non plus. le le repli le repli
sur soi tel que
le repli façon Trump, vous y croyez ou
pas
le repli façon Trump ? Oui, mais Trump
c'est une économie continent. C'est ça a
pas grand chose à voir avec ce qui est
la France. Tout ce qui est fait, on
parlait du général de Gold tout à
l'heure, tout ce qui fait euh la la la
grandeur et la force de la France, que
ce soit dans le domaine industriel ou
dans le domaine dans le domaine
agricole,
c'est fondamentalement des productions
qui sont tournées vers l'exportation.
Euh et donc ce ce priv d'exportation, le
le repli sur soi, le le localisme en
matière agricole euh ou le localisme
appliqué au secteur industriel, euh je
pense que ça ce sera la la ruine de la
France. à qui est-ce qu'on irait vendre
nos nos Airbus euh s'il n'y avait que
Air France pour les acheter encore euh
c'est plus français hein.
Bon euh non c'est c'est un autre sujet
mais euh bon donc en tout cas euh en
tout cas je je je
la la la la France a besoin de l'Europe.
Après ça dépend de quelle Europe de de
de quelle Europe on parle. On nous on
nous a fait brader, pardon, j'essayie de
terminer mon mon idée, exprimer ma
conviction. On nous a fait brader euh
des éléments de souveraineté nationale
en nous faisant miroiter que cette
souveraineté euh aurait plus de poids si
demain elle était
ça a été le le le le discours politique
ambiant au moment de référendum sur
Maich en 92. Euh et donc on nous a fait
on nous a fait échanger euh cette
souveraineté
nationale qui était
qui devenait quand même par certains
aspects de plus en plus relative. Enfin
sincèrement moi je suis content qu'on
soit pas resté au franc parce que on
serait peut-être dans une solution
totalement misérable. Faut pas raconter
d'histoire aux français, on n pas
beaucoup d'éléments pour pour le dire.
Mais enfin, qu'est-ce qu'aurait été la
crise de la crise des dettes souveraines
et cera si on avait été seulement
seulement en fran ? Quelle serait la
situation du franc aujourd'hui avec une
balance commerciale de 52 déficit de 52
milliards d'euros ? Je aujourd'hui on a
on a oublié ce qui étaient les
contraintes de la balance des paiements
pour la monnaie parce que on n'est plus
obligé d'acheter de libérer nos nos
achats enfin de de de sortir des devises
et de racheter en franc.
Donc donc par contre on nous a le on euh
l'opinion l'opinion enfin on nous a
convaincu ceux qui nous ont convaincu en
en 92 et après de de troquer notre
souveraineté c en échange d'une
souveraineté européenne qu'on aurait les
moyens d'exercer. Je constate
qu'aujourd'hui l'Europe effectivement
c'est pas exactement ça. Et et donc bah
tout l'enjeu c'est de c'est de c'est de
faire évoluer cette Europe très vite.
Sinon effectivement je pense que elle
éclatera.
Ah pour moi c'est c'est à l'échelle de
de l'actuelle commission. C'estàd qu'il
y a à l'échelle de l'actu commission, il
faut qu'il y a un virage à 180°
notamment sur notamment sur ces
contrôles. J'ai j'ai bon espoir quand
même que les choses évoluent assez vite.
regarder
regardz quand même la façon dont dont
aujourd'hui monsieur Macron lui-même a a
compris que la ratification du Mercur
était un était un problème parce que
juste on peut pas imposer des
contraintes aux récransur français et
malgré le en même temps signer des
accords de libre échange pour faire
faire rentrer des des des produits
agricoles qui ne sont pas soumis à ces
contraintes. Donc on on sait évoluer, on
sait évoluer assez vite, sera pas simple
en Europe.
Et sur les sujets sur les sujets de qui
touche à l'industrie, je pense qu'on a
exactement le même sujet. Il faut
évoluer évoluer très vite. Donc ce
premier règlement quand même sur le
contrôle des investissements étrangers à
l'échelle européenne, il me paraît quand
même assez satisfaisant. Je pense que
derrière, on a quand même un vrai
changement. Les gens qui pratiquent
Bruxelles au quotidien euh y compris les
spécialistes des questions de
d'intelligence économique reconnaissent
qu'il y a depuis euh un an ou deux un
spécialiste
un petit changement de
vous avez des noms là
un un un changement d'état d'esprit que
même au sein de la commission européenne
je permettez-moi aussi de rester garder
le secret des sources non mais je pense
il y a il y a un début de changement un
début de changement en l'état d'esprit
voilà je dis pas que je vous dis pas que
c'est réglé euh loin de là, mais je
pense que je pense qu'à Bruxelles, ils
ont quand même commencé à comprendre
qu'il y avait un vrai sujet.
Euh, on parle un peu de culture
française parce qu'il y a beaucoup de de
questions autour de ce sujet-là. Est-ce
qu'il y a une culture française ?
Écoutez, vous me bien sûr qu'il y a une
culture qu' a une culture française.
C'est quoi la culture française ?
Écoutez, la culture française c'est par
exemple la
la Renaissance française qui est qui est
une réalité. Euh c'est euh c'est le
c'est le siècle d'or euh et cette
culture euh forgée euh forgée au 17e
siècle enfin euh qui nous a valu des des
chef-dœuvres à la fois euh dans la
littérature, je pense à Cornail Racine
euh 17e euh au 18e. Oui, il y a une
culture il y a une culture française.
Vous êtes plutôt vous êtes plutôt Mara
ou Robespierre ?
Écoutez, je pense ni l'un ni l'autre.
Euh je sais pas quel est le sens de
votre question mais
non je je comprends pas le sens de votre
question en l'occurrence. C'est pas bien
terminé ni pour l'un ni pour l'un ni
pour l'autre. Euh
enfin oui la la moi je suis pas écoutez
j'ai j'ai aucune prétention culturelle
donc je suis pas très à l'aise pour pour
m'exprimer pour m'exprimer là-dessus.
Enfin vous m'interrogez sur ce qui
relève plutôt du à titre personnel de
d'un champ d'un champ relativement
relativement intime on va dire. Euh mais
oui, je crois qu'il y a une culture
évidemment qu'il y a une culture
française. Je pense qu'il y a il y a que
la France a
a fait rayonner quand même à travers le
monde
des des des valeurs.
un humanisme qui qui est né dans
l'esprit de à l'époque de la de la
Renaissance
qui a permis une une émergence des arts
au 17e au 18e siècle avec un un
foisonnement culturel et intellectuel
dans dans notre pays à cette époque qui
est quelque chose de d'assez fabuleux et
de et de qu'est-ce qu'il en reste
et et d'unique au monde
euh
et qui est vraiment qui est vraiment la
la signature française qui s'est plutôt
qui s'est s'est prolongé différemment au
19e siècle, au 18e, au 19e siècle, y
compris à travers à travers une période
coloniale
avec un bilan qui qui a malgré tout
des dimensions, une dimension positive
qu'il ne faut pas rayer rayer d'un trait
de plume où je pense qu'il y a une part
de de sincérité de tous les gens qui ont
qui ont voulu d'abord y compris y
compris des ordres des ordres des ordres
religieux et puis après de la 3e
République. Je sais qu'il y avait un
petit mélange des affaires déjà avec
entre politique et et affaires sur la 3e
République avec quelques quelques beaux
scandales, mais je pense qu'il y a aussi
une vraie volonté de faire propager les
valeurs de la Révolution française
à cette époque. Donc voilà, cette
culture française, c'est un héritage
aussi
qu'il faut qu'il faut défendre et ça
nous amène d'ailleurs à alors qu'est-ce
qu'il en reste ?
Voilà, la privatisation de la DP. Allez,
on ferme la parenthèse. On reviendra sur
Oui, c'est pas la clôture. Vous auriez
pu me dire le contrôle sur
l'investissement des médias que le
gouvernement s'apprête à euh s'apprête à
faire entrer dans le décret debourg en
quelque sorte. C'est étendre le champ du
contrôle des investissements étrangers
au médias pour espérer que ça serve
cette cause. Je suis pas sûr que ce soit
que ce soit ça qui soit visé mais chez
nous ça tombe bien, nous on est
entièrement financé par notre communauté
donc c'est très très bien. Euh on va
revenir sur ce petit côté un peu French
Terw juste après. On va parler tout de
suite de la privatisation d'ADP de la
Française des jeux de DF.
C'est on a vraiment plus de sous. On est
obligé de vendre les bijoux de famille.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Est-ce que pour
reprendre les mots de François Fillon,
on est tellement faillite queon est
obligé de de prendre un peu de cash. Moi
ma mon mon ma conviction là-dessus euh
c'est très très très clairement que
aujourd'hui
la la privatisation d'ADP, elle est
motivée essentiellement par le fait que
l'État veut tout faire, enfin que
monsieur Macron veut tout faire pour ne
pas franchir de manière trop visible le
seuil des 100 % d'endettement ramené par
rapport au PIB. Enfin, on tourne tour,
peut-être qu'on l'a déjà qu'on l'a déjà
dépassé, mais en tout cas, il faut pas
que ce soit trop flagrant. Euh, elle
veut pas avoir ça d'affiché à son bilan
et donc et donc la privatisation d'ADP
qui n'est pas du tout ce qu'on nous en a
dit parce qu'au début, on nous a dit on
va vendre ADP Française des jeux, on va
récupérer projeter et faire un fond pour
les investissements d'avenir. Donc vous
avez bien compris que c'est absolument
pas de ça dont il s'agit. en fait, on va
racheter un bout de dette française euh
et c'est les intérêts en fait de ces de
ces emprunts d'État qui euh qui
permettront de de de financer
annuellement un fond de soutien à la
recherche mais à hauteur, si j'ai bien
compris, de 200 millions d'euros par an.
Donc pour arriver ou 230, je sais plus,
mais en tout cas pour arriver au au 10
milliards, bah il faudra attendre 50 ans
à peu près. C'est ça. Euh voilà, donc il
y a un bel enfumage et la motivation
c'est les 100 % c'est les 100 % de
dette. On est bien d'accord. C'est ce
n'est que ça. Donc oui, c'est c'est
dramatique
et je fais partie de ceux qui n'ont
aucun état d'âme. Moi, je regrette que
dans ma famille politique, on a été
assez on a donné le sentiment qu'on
était à la remorque de de certains
savoir que la l'idée d'enclencher
d'ailleurs un référendum d'initiative
un peu votre pied parce qu'il y a la
late du parquet qui fait un peu de
bruit.
Pardon. le l'idée d'enclencher le
référendum d'initiative populaire.
D'ailleurs, c'est une idée d'une députée
républicain, Marie-Christine d'Allose,
qui a été récupérée cette idée par par
la gauche. On en assume totalement la la
la pérennité. Euh évidemment que
évidemment que Aéroport de Paris est une
infrastructure stratégique d'importance
vitale. Je dirais, on ne discuterait
même pas d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de la
privatisation s'il y avait pas eu l'État
pour pour réaliser ADP. J'ai c'est tous
les investissements ont été portés parce
que parce que l'État l'a voulu par les
contribuables français. Là encore,
c'était une volonté Roissi, c'est la
volonté Roy Charles de Gaul, c'est la
volonté du général de Gaulle.
Donc c'est pas une création spontanée du
marché et c'est au moment où cet
investissement devient le plus rentable
où il devient un enjeu considérable
parce que les hub ont besoin de enf les
compagnies aériennes ont besoin de de de
plateformes de ce type et que la
plateforme d'ADP est une plateforme
enfin de Paris en tout cas est une
plateforme formidable que l'État
deviendrait illégitime. Donc moi je ne
crois pas du tout effectivement à cette
à cet enfumage et je pense que les gens
qui dans la famille politique ont des
états d'âes sont été des gens pas pas
très bien informé. que je plaide
inlassablement en disant "Mais regardez
un peu l'histoire, j'ai c'est l'État qui
a tout financé. Pourquoi au moment où ça
devient rentable, l'État deviendra
illégitime avec derrière des des enjeux
des enjeux importants en terme de en
terme de de souveraineté ? C'est une
fois encore le contrôle de notre
frontière, c'est notre principale
frontière ADP. Euh on sait aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs quels sont les les
dysfonctionnements d'avoir parfois
recours sur certains contrôles des
barrigages et cetera des prestataires
privés. Donc si on veut continuer à
dégrader l'image de la France et et le
caséchant, le sérieux de la façon dont
on accomplit cette mission, euh
continuons qu'on fasse gérer les
boutiques par des partenaires privés. Je
pense que d'ailleurs c'est déjà parti de
cas. Euh c'est c'est n'évidemment pas
une difficulté mais je je ne partage pas
cette à cette religion de la
disqualification systématique de l'État.
Nous sommes un pays qui a cette
particularité
d'avoir à la fois une industrie et puis
quelques éléments qui sont le produit de
allez ce qu'on appellera une espèce de
de colbertisme. Euh je pense qu'il faut
pas en avoir honte et il faut pas les
brader dans n'importe quelle condition.
Euh ceux qui nous ont donné une très
belle leçon d'ailleurs de de de vrai
libéralisme et de ce que doit être le le
rôle de l'État y compris dans une
économie de marché, c'est ce sont les
Hollandais.
C'estàd que au moment où je rappelle que
les Pays-Bas sont un vrai pays libéral
avec un taux d'imposition sur les
sociétés de 23 % c'est qui qui ferait
rêver qui est le deuxième plus faible en
Europe qui qui peut faire rêver les
chefs d'entreprise français un certain
nombre d'ailleurs malheureusement des
ménages un autre sujet donc c'est un
vrai pays libéral en terme de en terme
de de pression fiscale.
Si c'est 13 % la Lituénie je crois que
c'est 6 et demi.
Je je sais pas. En tout cas euh en tout
cas les les Pays-Bas sont un pays
beaucoup plus libéral que la France de
fiscalité sur les entreprises. Euh et et
bien qu'on fait les Pays-Bas le jour où
on a annoncé la privatisation d'aéroport
de Paris, ils sont montés, ils ont
nationalisé un peu plus Airfance KLM en
montant de passant de 5 à 15 % dans le
capital de l'ensemble Air France KLM au
même niveau que l'État français. un très
joli pied de nez à l'équipe à l'équipe
Macron en disant nous qui sommes un pays
libéral et ben on sait défendre nos
intérêts nationaux. Nos intérêts
nationaux en l'occurrence c'est cette
compagnie franco-néerlandaise et c'est
l'aéroport de Chipolsterdam
qu'ils n'ont pas envie de voir sacrifier
par les décisions qui seront prises par
des pays. Accessoirement, on a aussi des
enjeux quand même d'aménagement du
territoire. C'estàd que le jour où
l'exploitant dira "Attendez, moi je
préfère euh avoir les des avions
américains en transit plutôt que d'avoir
l'avion de Hope qui euh qui décercle à
Montferrand ou Limoge. Euh aujourd'hui,
il faut déjà prendre un quart et faire
une demi-heure de quart avant de pouvoir
monter dans un avion pour
Clermontferrand." Bon bah demain
effectivement on peut nous dire non bah
attendez vous allez prendre le car
jusqu'à Carmontferrand on mettra dessus
une bannière vers France ça vous fait
plaisir mais donc derrière on a un vrai
enjeu sur vous irez à Beauvet où vous
irez je ne sais où pour prendre l'avion
pour Camonfer donc derrière il y a des
vrais sujets aussi d'aménagement du
territoire important pour
franise des jeux
pour les Français
la française des jeux je suis un tout
petit peu plus partagé mais enfin bon il
y a quand même derrière des des enjeux
des enjeux d'addiction et cetera qui
voilà bon j'ai j'ai un tout petit peu
moins de religion sur sur la française
F
EDF là on est sur un sujet sur un sujet
très grave avec effectivement deux
sujets.
Le sujet des barrages hydrauliques qui
qui qui est le premier dans le temps
avec
on risque d'être le seul pays en Europe
à ouvrir nos barrages à la concurrence.
Il y a un excellent rapport
parlementaire, il faut il y a de temps
en temps d'excellents rapports
parlementaires et celui de Marie Noël
Baptistel député euh qui n'est pas de ma
famille politique en occurrence un
excellent travail soumise
non non député de socialiste de l'ISER
et elle a fait un excellent travail puis
au moins de de benchmarking sur la façon
dont les les barrages sont gérés en
Europe et elle a mis en évidence que les
Allemands qui ont fait du lobby auprès
de la Commission européenne depuis des
années pour que la France ouvre ses
barrages à la concurrence que les
Allemands eux Eux sont dans un système
de d'autorisation administrative qui
fait qu'ils n'ont pas ouvert leur
barrage à la concurrence. On est quand
même dans un superbe foutage de gueule
dans cette affaire. Et bien malgré tout,
ce que j'observe c'est que la France
visiblement
ne fait
n'a pas fait beaucoup de lobbing et n'a
pas beaucoup fait preuve de résistance
auprès de de Bruxelles sur la mise en
jeu de ces barrages et l'ouverture à la
concurrence de de nos barrages avec
pourtant de vrais enjeux de sécurité.
Euh, il est évident quand on a des
barrages qui commencent à avoir comme
certains 60 75 ans, euh il y a un vrai
euh un vrai enjeu derrière de de
rénovation, de de surveillance, de euh
vieillissement du béton et cetera. Euh
je suis pas sûr que tous les exploitants
privés offriront les mêmes garanties de
de sérieux dans l'exploitation de ces
barrages. Donc, on pourrait très bien,
ce sont des des infrastructures
d'importance vitale en terme de de de de
notre droit. On pourrait très bien
s'opposer à leur ouverture, à la
concurrence. simplement, j'observe que
depuis les années Macron que ce ce sujet
est en concurrence, les années Macron
elles ont commencé sur François Hollande
les les Français l'ont l' oublié mais
enfin monsieur Macron a été le le
ministre de l'économie, le penseur
économique de François Hollande donc
depuis 7 ans en tout cas qu'il pilote la
politique économique de la France,
visiblement cette question de la
privatisation enfin de de l'ouverture à
la concurrence de nos barrages euh est
un sujet sur lequel la France n'a fait
aucun effort pour convaincre Bruxelles
de ne pas passer à l'acte. Le deuxième
sujet auquel on arrive, c'est cet
étonnant projet de cission de DF. C'est
assez fabuleux de la part. Pardon de
faire peut-être un peu de politique sur
sur ce sur votre site où habituellement
on en fait pas pas trop. Enfin, si vous
avez monsieur Mélenchon qui en a fait un
peu peut-être. Euh mais ce projet de de
sission de DF, il est aussi totalement
extravagant. Le gouvernement actuel
passe son temps depuis 2 ans puis il
avait fait avant avec les fus à nous
vanter les mérite des fusions
acquisition. L'alpha et l'oméga la
politique industrielle de monsieur
Macron c'est une politique de fusion
acquisition. C'est le cas d'Alstom Power
le cas de d'Alstom Simas a avorté le cas
d'Alcatel le cas de Technipp le cas
d'Alfarge passon. On a fait avoir Fiat
Fiat Renault.
Et bien étonnamment là où on a avec EDF
un champion européen, on a même le
vice-champion du monde, il était
champion du monde d'ailleurs jusqu'à une
fusion entre deux géants chinois il y a
il y a a y a il y a de ou 3 ans, mais il
est toujours le deuxième électricien au
monde, donc c'est pas rien. Et bien, on
est en train de nous expliquer que là,
il faut le scinder en deux. C'est c'est
quand même étonnant.
Il m'avait dit en riant mais tu vois les
arc c'est formidable. quand j'étais
étudiant en science pour euh un prof qui
prof d'éco qui devait pas être énarque
dit un un énarc quand il a deux trucs,
il en fait un quand il en a un il en
fait deux quoi. Bon donc on est
complètement là-dedans. Parle d'enar
devenu inspecteur des filles, devenu
banquier d'affaires en l'occurrence euh
probablement. Euh donc on nous propose
aujourd'hui la cission de DF en deux
entités, ce qui est une une espèce
d'abération évidemment parce que ce qui
fait aujourd'hui la la la force de DF,
ça reste ça reste son intégration
notamment la capacité qu'on a par
exemple avec euh avec les barrages
hydrauliques de pouvoir euh injecter de
de de l'énergie quand on a des pics de
consommation. Donc c'est une fabuleuse
euh c'est une fabuleuse batterie quoi.
C'est on s'interroge sur le stockage de
l'énergie avec l'hydraulique on sait
faire. Je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui les
barrages hydrauliques en France, c'est
la première source euh d'énergie
renouvelable. C'est 13 % de de l'énergie
consommée par les Français. Donc juste
après le nucléaire, c'est la seconde
source d'énergie. On est très très loin
évidemment devant le photovoltaïque ou
ou l'éolien. Bon et bien on s'apprête à
à scinder EDF en deux avec
un montage qui est vraiment totalement
désastreux. C'estàd qu'on sait que ce
qui va avoir besoin d'argent dans
l'avenir, enfin ce qui en a besoin en ce
moment, ce qui absorbe d'ailleurs en ce
moment la majeure partie des des 15
milliards d'euros 15 milliards d'euros
comme d'investissement annuel de DF,
c'est notamment le notamment le
nucléaire avec des OPR à terminer avec
un chantier du grand carénage pour pour
100 milliards d'euros. de quoi faire
bosser des entreprises françaises
derrière, donner un petit peu de travail
euh à nos compatriotes, 100 milliards
d'euros de grand carénage à venir dans
les années qui viennent. Bon, donc on
sait que le nucléaire va avoir besoin
d'un peu d'argent. Et bien étonnamment,
d'après ce que ce que monsieur Lévi a
présenté euh à son comité d'entreprise,
à son top management,
monsieur le maire me dit aujourd'hui
qu'il était pas au courant à l'Assemblée
nationale, c'est quand même c'est
inquiétant. Euh et bien tout ça serait
serait totalement adossé à l'État. ça
appelle ça EDF bleu et ce serait
renationalisé dans un espèce de Cocorico
trompeur tel que monsieur le maire sait
très très bien les faire c'est le le le
le chentre du Cocorico trompeur donc il
va nous dire en faisant de la gonflette
on renationalise regardez on est on est
vraiment irréprochable on assume de
responsabilité on se donne des moyens
mais bon en réalité adossé à l'état
cette def bleu ressemble plutôt à une
espèce de société de défaisance avec des
barrages qui vont qui vont être cédés et
un nucléaire pour lequel on n'ura pas a
les moyens de faire de faire les
travaux. Et par contre, ce qu'on ouvre
davantage à la concurrence, c'est tout
le reste, ce qu'ils appellent le DF vert
avec les services, la distribution
et les énergies noir. En fait, tout ce
qui aujourd'hui est plutôt rentable et
ce qui fait un peu fantasmer les marchés
les marchés financiers, voilà, en
réalité, on va désintégrer EDF, ça va
être le seul résultat et on va arriver à
un résultat catastrophique. Donc ce
projet de sisson de DF, soyons soyons
très clair, ça ne peut pas être un
projet industriel. J'ai l'intime
conviction qu'il ne vient pas ne peut
pas venir de l'intérieur de
l'entreprise. J'ai rencontré personne
qui m'a dit qu'il venait de l'intérieur
de l'entreprise et que c'était monsieur
monsieur Lévi qui avait cogité et qui
avait trouvé ça tout seul. Donc c'est un
projet qui de toute évidence a été vendu
à l'État par je ne sais quelle banque
d'affaires euh qui voilà une formidable
opportunité de se rémunérer
sur sur l'assission et puis qui sait que
ça fera un peu frétiller des marchés
financiers avec cette ouverture au
capital de EDF de EDF vert pour un
résultat qui sera sans doute totalement
dérisoire et ridicule parce que EDF va
sans doute pas gagner d'argent en
déployant des panneaux photovoltaïques
chinois ou en posant des éoliennes
allemandes.
Question d'Internet. Parlez-nous de Hug
Bély, ancien conseiller de Macron à Beru
directeur général de général électrique
France.
Oui. Alors là, on revient un peu à la
question de l'entre mélange des genres
et des pantouflages
parfois surprenants, voir douteux. Euh
qu'en clair, monsieur Huc Bella était un
des collaborateurs d'Embonel Macron euh
à son cabinet que ministre de l'économie
et euh pardon, je sais plus si c'est
avant ou après, mais il a été aussi à la
direction générale du du trésor et il
est parti
de ces fonctions donc pour occuper
d'abord une fonction de lobbyiste, de
chargé de relation institutionnelle chez
général électrique puis euh de président
France de général électrique. Alors ce
qui est assez amusant, c'est que il
était un drôle de lobbiste puisqueen
fait il avait une d'après ce que on
avait dit, je crois la FP, il avait
la commission de déontologie lui avait
interdit d'entrer en relation avec ses
anciens collègues de du cabinet Macron,
c'estàd que et de Berily, c'està-dire
qu'en clair, comme le big en chef de
général électrique, il n'avait pas le
droit de parler par exemple à Alexis
Coler, secrétaire général de l'Élysée en
charge des dossiers économiques et il
avait pas le droit de parler évidemment
à Emmanuel Macron. On comprend peut-être
mieux pourquoi, je dis ça évidemment ri
pourquoi
a si mal dialogué avec l'État ces ces
deux dernières ces deux dernières
années. Bon euh donc premier premier
premier hic et puis deè deuxème hic qui
était le le signalement je crois fait
par par Delphine Bateau qui qui a
justifié sa récente la récente ouverture
d'une d'une enquête préliminaire.
C'est la question de savoir s'il avait
le droit d'aller tout simplement au-delà
des interdictions relation, est-ce qu'il
avait le droit d'aller travailler dans
une entreprise comme Général Electrique
alors que ça sa fonction au cabinet de
d'Emmanuel Macron était euh d'après ce
que disent les les organigrammes qu'on
connaît encore hein du cabinet
d'Emmanuel Macron était le était les
tout tout ce qui était contrat contrat
COFAS contrat contrat d'export et les
premiers bénéficiaires en France des
contrats d'export c'est Airbus et
immédiatement Après c'était Alstom et
déjà le général électrique. Donc
vous connaissez bien la coface ?
Non non pas pas pas particulièrement.
Non
passe on passe le bonjour à Jérôme Kaz.
Donc en tout cas voilà l'interrogation
je crois qu' a été soulevée et est
celle-là. Euh bon, j'ai le sentiment
qu'évidemment c'est pas le hasard qu'il
a amené à passer du cabinet d'Emmanuel
Macron euh à Mercy à général électrique
après. C'était sans doute la volonté du
président de la République d'avoir à
général électrique un interlocuteur un
petit peu privilégié pour essayer de
gérer l'épineux dossier gén électrique.
Si on veut faire un petit bilan en en
trois mots plus plus 1
du du bilan quand même de la vente de la
branche énergie d'stom génér électrique,
c'est le mariage entrega qu'on nous a
vendu que que monsieur Macron nous a
vendu à l'époque avec trois John Venture
dans lesquels il y avait parité entre
Hstom et General Electric. John Venture
ont disparu de de la de la surface de la
terre. C'est-à-dire que Alstom a été
autorisé à ce euh en courant 2018 début
2018 à tout vendre à à sortir de ces
trois cours entreprise. Donc la fable du
mariage entrega que qu'on nous vend
toujours que que les banques d'affaires
nous vendent chaque opération de fusion
acquisition à la fait long feu. Tout le
monde stom a repris ses billes. Euh les
les 1000 emplois qui devaient être créés
évidemment ne l'ont pas été et
aujourd'hui on a un plan social de de
1000 emplois sur lesquels avec
l'intersyéndical de général électrique à
Bfort, on a quand même rappelé à
monsieur monsieur le maire
qui avait quand même un petit peu de
droit à faire et que justement dans les
engagements qui avaient été pris par les
Américains général électrique en 2014
lors du rachat d'alstom, ils s'étaient
engagés aussi à maintenir en France
leurs activités de turbine à gaz même si
en fait elle relevait d'une précédente
d'une précédente acquisition. Et donc on
a rappelé à monsieur Bruno Lemaire que
c'était sa responsabilité personnelle
comme ministre de l'économie de
s'assurer du respect des des des accords
pris lors des investissements étrangers
en France. Une fois encore quand le Stom
acheté, ça a été sur la foie
d'engagement. Il serait peut-être temps
de les faire d'essayer au moins de faire
semblant d'en faire respecter
quelques-uns.
Alors, j'ai un commentaire de Romain, un
internaute qui nous dit "Monsieur
Marlex, exbaladurien et sarcosiste,
s'fusque de la main mise des USA sur
Alstom. Mais le retour dans l'OTAN et le
proaméricanisme de Sarkozy ne le
gênaiit-il pas ? car le rachat d'Alstom
est la suite logique de la politique
pro-américaine de SarkoZi et de la
faiblesse de Hollande.
Ouais, je je je suis pas certain qu'on
puisse faire le un un raccourci aussi
direct.
La réintégration de l'OTAN par SarkoZi,
c'était bien. Le général de Gaulle, il
fait combien de flips dans son cercueil
là ?
Ouais,
sur enfin on a ré
On est en double flip sauté quand même.
Non, pardon, pardon, on a réintégré euh
enfin je suis pas non plus un
spécialiste des affaires étrangères. Ah
bah alors
je suis pas SP mais je vous ai dit très
honnêtement en commençant que moi je
suis rentré dans ce sujet al stom par
plutôt avec ma casquette d'ailleurs de
juriste de voir comment respecter des
procédures. Donc je prétends pas ni un
spécialiste des questions de culture ni
un spécialiste des affaires étrangères
je pense que
réintégrer un commandement intégrer un
commandement unique de l'OTAN et
accepter
et accepter de participer au côté de nos
alliés américains, nos amis américains.
Je le dis sans sans sans sans sourire
totalement. Je pense que les États-Unis
d'Amérique sont quand même une nation
avec laquelle dans ce monde on partage
un certain nombre de valeurs.
C'est le le président du cercle
Jefferson qui nous parle.
Oui, tout à fait, tout à fait. Euh mais
je termine sur je termine sur le temps,
pu je veux bien vous répondre sur sur le
cercle de Jefferson. Euh,
comment dire ? Enfin voilà, réintégrer
ce commandement intégré dont on peut
reclaquer la porte, ça nous amuse demain
hein. Si si oui, d'accord.
C'est c'est quand même pas le même
les balles de FAMAS, elles sont faites à
Saint-Étienne maintenant ou pas ? C'est
pas le niveau de C'est pas le même
niveau de de contrainte que de que de
renoncer que niveau d'engagement que de
renoncer définitivement à des à des
outils de de stratégique qu'on ne sait
plus fabriquer. les turbinesignement
les turbines les turbines arabelles par
exemple dans les accords et cetera, on a
c'est un mourir de rire, on a on a on
s'est assuré qu'on pourrait utiliser la
licence gratuitement pour pour
refabriquer demain une turbine arabelle
si généric refusait de nous en fournir.
Ça c'est une énorme Oui, c'est une
énorme blague. C'est une fumisterie,
c'est une plaisanterie, c'est ce que
vous voulez parce que le jour où vous
avez plus les savoir-faire, ouvriers,
les ingénieurs, tout ça derrière pour
reconstruire une turbine arabelle, on en
sera totalement incapable de se
savoir-faire. Ils se perdent évidemment
en quelques en quelques années. Donc
donc pour moi, c'est pas c'est pas la
même chose le sujet le sujet de temps
sur la relation avec les États-Unis. Moi
je dire dire très franchement qu'une
fois encore, je dirais les États-Unis
sont un pays amis depuis depuis la
déclaration leur déclaration
d'indépendance, le regard. Êtes-vous
bien sûr que les États-Unis sont
toujours nos omis ?
Alors non, pardon, je je termine. Oui,
peut-être pas que et des amis dont il
faut qu'il faut regarder avec euh avec
comment dire avec vigilance et avec et
sans aucune naïveté. Euh mais enfin, je
je pense que dans ce monde un tout petit
peu un tout petit peu incertain, petit
peu instable, les États-Unis d'Amérique
sont quand même une nation avec les avec
laquelle nous partageons euh énormément
de énormément de valeur.
Vous voulez pas montrer ça ? Vous voulez
pas montrer ça à la caméra ? 2 secondes
?
Non, ça me gêne de faire de la publicité
pour un livre, mais j'aurais préféré
j'aurais préféré monter celui de celui
de Frédéric Pirouci. D'ailleurs,
j'aurais pu le faire.
Montrez-le voir à la caméra là. Comment
comment il s'appelle ce monsieur là ?
Mais non, mais on va on va en parler et
on va en parler surité. Mais une fois
encore qu'il y a pas de qui a pas de de
j'ai aucun problème à assumer l'amitié
franco-américaine. Je pense qu'une fois
encore dans ce dans ce dans ce monde
dans ce monde complexe, on a le droit de
dire de penser que la nation américaine,
le peuple américain est un peuple allié,
est un peuple qui nous ressemble et
cetera. Une fois que vous avez pardon
une fois que que que vous avez et moi
c'est dans cet esprit que je fais partie
de de gens qui après le le le 11
septembre 2001
ont créé en France une association des
anciens visiteurs internationaux, c'est
de des gens qui ont été invités à un
moment par un programme d'échange
financé par le gouvernement américain à
visiter les États-Unis. Euh c'est un
magnifique programme qui permet vraiment
de découvrir les États-Unis de long en
large et en travers et à mieux les
comprendre. Les hôtels sont bien. Est-ce
que la cantine est bonne ? C'est tout
financé par C'est tout financé par nos
amis américains.
Les le voyage, il dure 5 6 semaines. Les
Américains vous accueillent très bien.
Vous êtes souvent accueillis dans des
familles américaines et je vous assure
que c'est c'est un moment des
personnalités politiques de droite de
gauche ont fait ce programme et je crois
que tous les grands pays ont des
programmes de ce type France a à peu
près à peu près le l'équivalent. Donc
j'ai je rougis pas du tout ni d'avoir
fait ce programme, ni d'avoir voulu
cultiver après le le 11 septembre 2001
l'amitié franco-américaine. Je vous
rappelle quei en matière de
renseignement, je pense qu'on travaille
quand même aussi beaucoup beaucoup avec
les Américains. Il y a il y a
aujourd'hui encore enfin et chaque jour
probablement des échanges d'information
avec les Américains pour pour notre
Est-ce que les Américains travaillent
avec nous
pour notre sécurité ? Bien sûr, bien
sûr, bien sûr que les services de
renseignement nous améli nous donnent
aussi des informations.
À partir de là, effectivement, il faut
pas être naïf.
Qu'est-ce que vous appelez naïf ? Alors,
je vous attendez, je reprends le micro
une petite seconde. Quand je vois quand
je vois quand je vois ma présidence se
faire écouter depuis les trois ou quatre
derniers mandat,
c'est un scandale, c'est un scandale
absolu.
Quand je vois que l'ambassade américaine
à Paris a un toit aussi fourni en
antenne que le cul de l'aéroport de de
de de de
Charles de Gaulle,
Ouais. En plein Paris, quand je vois euh
des fleurons,
nos bijoux de famille se faire découper,
je me pose la question : où est la
naïveté ? Où est la naïveté ? Et où est
notre courage ?
Cette question est intéressante que j'ai
posé à peu près cette question là au
patron au patron des enquêtes
internationales euh
au département of justice des des
États-Unis.
Et je je lui ai je lui ai demandé,
s'appelle Bruce Bruce Schwarz, c'est le
le monsieur, le type qui dirige toutes
les enquêtes internationales auprès de
la Tornet générale.
Je lui ai dit
général,
procureur général des États-Unis, il
faut quand même bien avoir à l'esprit
que cette justice américaine, c'est pas
la justice au sens où on l'entend nous.
C'est-à-dire que c'est pas des juges
indépendants, ce sont des juges élus, ce
sont des politiques et la tend générale
c'est le c'est le ministre nommé par le
gouvernement. Donc le le département of
justice en réalité sont des procureurs
nommés par le gouvernement. Donc c'est
le gouvernement
seul bras armé du gouvernement et c'est
pas du tout effectivement euh le bras
armé du euh
du syndicat de la magistrature par non
pardon je plaisante euh de de de de de
la justice de la justice française. Ça
n'a rien à voir. Bon donc ça doit amener
à une autre lucidité. Donc j'ai demandé
à ce j'ai évoqué avec ce brouchoir c'est
un certain nombre de d'enquêtes qu'ils
ont mené en disant ce qui notamment ce
qui a de gênant ce qui a de gênant c'est
c'est les moyens que vous utilisez.
J'avais j'avais à l'esprit notamment une
des dépêches révélées par Snowden euh
qui parlait dans la laquelle la NSA
demande à ses agents de lui faire
remonter toutes les informations
possibles sur tous les contrats français
de plus de 200 millions de dollars dans
les secteurs comme par hasard de la
sécurité, de la défense, des télécoms,
de l'énergie, des transports et de la
santé. C'est ce qu'on appelle nos
secteurs stratégiques. Euh et donc cet
intérêt des services de renseignement
américain pour les contrats passés,
évidemment on
c'est pour nous aider.
C'est pas que pour nous aider. Vous avez
vous avez raison. Euh de la même façon
euh Pierre Lelouche qui a fait un
excellent rapport sur avec Karine
Berger, encore un excellent rapport
parlementaire euh après enfin en plein
moment de de l'amende sur BNP Pariba-
Bas de 9 milliards de dollars euh
de record qui aurait pu par terre
système bancaire français euh a demandé
un certain nombre d'explications et lui
il a il a l'intime conviction
qu'effectivement les moyens
d'information récoltés par les
Américains l'ont été par des moyens
moyen non conventionnel. Et quand je
pose cette question à Bruce Schwartz
disant mais ce qu'on vous reproche c'est
pas de c'est pas de vous faire les
gendarmes de la corruption dans le monde
contre les entreprises françaises.
D'ailleurs, faut avoir à l'honnêteté de
dire qu'ils le font aussi de temps en
temps contre les entreprises contre les
entreprises américaines. Si si bah
regardez par exemple quand même l'action
en ce moment de de je sais plus combien
de procureurs américains sur Google pour
pour position dominante. montre que même
aux États-Unis, il commence à y avoir
des petits sujets de réflexion face à un
géant américain qui est en train de le
peut-être de leur échapper qui échappe à
la puissance publique. Donc je ferme je
ferme la parenthèse mais non quand vous
regardez le le tableau de chasse des
Américains,
l'Europe on est bien d'accord est la
première cible avec un prélèvement
estimé par Pierre Lelouche à une
vingtaine de milliards d'euros en
quelques années sur l'économie
européenne. Mais vous avez quand même un
certain nombre de d'affaires importantes
sur les Américains. Ce que je lui
reproche donc c'est effectivement c'est
l'utilisation de moyens non
conventionnels. Et la réponse très
froide de que me fait Bruce Schwartz
c'est mais moyen de renseignement mais
vous avez exactement les mêmes.
Utilisez-les. Donc les les les
Américains sont des amis des alliés très
francs qui vous disent "Mais oui
effectivement on est dans une guerre
économique il y a grosso modo que vous
qui vous voulez pas le voir, qui faites
sans doute semblant de pas le voir."
Effectivement, on en revient à votre
question de tout à l'heure. Est-ce qu'on
est naïf ou est-ce qu'on est coupable ?
Je pense qu'on est pas naïf. Je pense
qu'on est coupable à ce niveau-là en
France. et qu'une partie de
de nos dirigeants sont coupables
dirigeants politiques ou administratifs
sont coupables de de de cette du naïveté
feinte. Donc les Américains nous disent
"Oui, nous sommes en guerre économique,
nous nous utilisons tous les moyens à
notre disposition. Euh vous êtes
vraiment des cloches de ne pas de ne pas
vous défendre et de pas utiliser les
mêmes moyens." Voilà.
Cloche en anglais.
Moi, je vous invite à à interroger par
exemple euh
foutez de ma question.
Non, je suis pas sûr d'avoir la réponse.
Euh, c'est
c'est belle ou dump ?
Bon, écoutez, je suis pas non plus pour
donner des leçons d'anglais, donc
laissez-moi dans mon domaine de de
travail. Euh moi, je vous invite à à
inviter par exemple un jour Charles
Duchen qui est le patron de l'Agence
Française Anticorruption.
Vous avez son 06
peut-être euh
ce qui Moi, j'ai eu peur quand on a créé
dans la loi Sapin 2 cette cette agence
française anticorruption. J'ai eu peur
qu'on se tire une balle dans le pied,
que qu'on crée un machin qui par lequel
on viendrait mettre une seconde couche.
C'est que non seulement on avait les
Américains sur le dos, mais en plus
maintenant on allait avoir l'Agence
française anticorruption qui allait
venir donner des leçons et balancer des
entreprises françaises au parquet. Euh
je suis pas le porte-parole de de
Charles Duchen, mais je l'ai entendu
dire des choses extrêmement lucides et
fortes dans des dans des congrès sur des
questions de de de complence notamment
euh où il explique très très clairement
que les Américains utilisent aujourd'hui
tous les moyens en leur possession pour
euh trouver des moyens de
déstabilisation de nos entreprises.
qu'il invite les entreprises françaises
à arrêter de faire preuve de de naïveté
et donc ce serait bien effectivement que
lorsqu'il s'agit d'entreprise d'état ou
d'entreprises stratégiques, l'État
français arrête aussi de faire preuve de
de de naïveté. Voilà. Donc
effectivement, les Américains sont des
alliés, des amis d'un genref le peuple
américain est un peuple ami.
L'administration américaine, elle a des
pratiques un peu différente. Faut juste
faut juste le savoir et juste et juste
le comprendre pour pour leur parler des
galégales. Et je vous invite là aussi
par exemple à écouter un jour et à
discuter avec un garçon comme comme
Pierre Lelouche que qu'on peut pas qu'on
peut pas soupçonner de de de détester
l'Amérique. qui a même plutôt fait
figure de de de de d'atlantiste ou de ou
de proaméricain pendant les nombreuses
années où il a été conseiller
diplomatique de Jacques Chirac ou ou
ministre auprès de de de Nicolas
Sarkozy. C'est évidence un vrai ami des
Américains, mais il connaît tellement
bien les États-Unis qu'il n'a aucune
naïveté et aucune illusion sur ce dont
les Américains sont capables. Donc
amitié doit rimer avec lucidité
et pas
et pas naïveté.
Ah ouais et pas
Vous l'avez senti celui-là ? Non. Dir
non je sais pas.
On on va finir. Bon quelques quelques
questions euh sur les préconisations.
Je vous le rends quand même je pas
l'abîmer.
Hop là. Vous inquiétez pas, on lui fera
une dédicace pour vous si vous voulez.
Euh les préconisations pour endurcir nos
sociétés, c'est plus de contrôle, moins
de contrôle, virer la classe politique,
couper des têtes, faire des exemples,
enclouer un sur la porte. Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ? pour éviter que ça se
refasse.
Pour éviter que ça se reproduise. C'est
mon grand-père en aurait attrapé un, il
l'aurait cloué sur la porte histoire de
faire un exemple ou juste à l'entrée du
village
avec les corbeaux sur les épaules.
Écoutez, je je sais pas en tout cas, moi
je j'espère que par exemple les enquêtes
du parquet national financier sur les
conditions d'avant d'alstom permettront
de permettront d'aller plus loin en
terme d'investigation et de vérifier si
effectivement il y a pas des jeux
d'influence
dans des décisions prises par les
pouvoirs publics français qui sont qui
sont coupables. Effectivement, je j'ai
cette ce sentiment aujourd'hui que
la politique industrielle de la France,
elle est dicté par des banques
d'affaires
au nom de de leurs intérêts personnels,
intérêt privé personnel de quelques
personnes euh et qu' en face
qui en soit n'est pas coupable
d'ailleurs enfin tout le monde a le
droit de de s'enrichir par son travail.
Ce qui est coupable, c'est que ceux qui
sont en charge de défendre les intérêts
nationaux soient aussi bienveillants.
Alors dire parfois ils professeent la
bienveillance mais je pense qu'il faut
il y a des fonctions sur lesquelles on n
pas le droit de d'être d'être naïf,
d'être bienveillant. Donc voilà,
j'espère que les investigations
permettront de de de vérifier peut-être
de de de sanctionner des gens s'il y a
eu si si on a autre autre passé, s'il y
a des des des pratiques qui ne sont pas
qui sont pas admissibles. Et ma
conviction, c'est que malheureusement
effectivement ce genre de ce genre
d'influence continue.
J'ai j'ai auditionné dans la commission
d'enquête et l'audition était publique
une une banque d'affaires qui a
revendiqué, je vais la citer celle-là
sur cette audition, c'était c'était
c'était la la banque Rchild
qui
revendique au effort
son droit
à dialoguer avec les pouvoirs publics en
ne s'appliquant pas les règles de la
haute autorité transparence aux public
c'estàd les règles de la loiin 2 de
représentation d'intérêt et c'est un
scandale. Moi j'ai même posé je connais
l'espritateur qui trouve que j'ai posé
cette question de manière très précise à
Michel Sapin ministre de l'économie qui
était au banc au moment de la loi Sapin
Sapa 2. Je dis mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe si par exemple un inspecteur des
finances devenu banquier d'affaires
essaie d'influer sur une décision au
titre du contrôle des investissements
étrangers ? C'est rigolo parce que ça
peut ressembler un peu à ce qui s'est
passé sur l'affaire Alstom ou autre. Euh
réponse du du ministre sapin. Bien
évidemment, on rentrera dans le champ du
contrôle. Il se trouve qu'il y a eu un
décret le 9 mai 2017, j'appelle le
décret du dernier jour par Bernard
Casneuve qui a donné une définition de
de l'entrée en relation qui permet à un
certain nombre de personnes de s'en
exonérer euh de prétendre s'en exonérer
en disant "Moi, je fais moins de 50 % de
mon temps en entrant en relation en
lobbying ou je fais moins de 10 entrées
en relation par an. Donc tout ça me
concerne pas." Bon, c'est évidemment une
espèce de de foutage de gueule cette
réponse. Il est évident que la loi SP2
doit s'appliquer aux banques d'affaires
et je le dis très sérieusement, je pense
que si les banques d'affaires continuent
à jouer ce rôle- làà c'estàdire à
considérer qu'elles peuvent influer sur
des décisions, sur des sessions dans des
secteurs stratégiques, je pense qu'ils
vont au-delà de enfin ils prennent
d'énormes risques, y compris en matière
pénale aujourd'hui. Voilà. Donc avis
avis aux amateurs.
On fait pas la porte alors non
pardon. Alors sur la porte pour
poursuivre sur la suite de sur la suite
des des réponses. Donc un process
juridique euh je l'espère aujourd'hui
sera un tout petit peu plus un tout
petit peu plus respecté. plus
sérieusement, comment enfin plus
fondamentalement parce que tout ça est
quand même très très sérieux mais plus
fondamentalement
comment on empêche de disparaître même
une entreprise qui est pas dans le dans
dans le champ. Enfin, je pense qu' a
deux éléments de réponse. Le le premier
c'est vraiment que l'État se remette à
identifier ce qu'il considère comme
stratégique. J'ai je me souviens
en est-il capable ?
Bien sûr, bien sûr qu'il en est capable.
La DGA la DGA le fait très bien.
Pourquoi est-ce que Bercy le fait pas ?
D'ailleurs, ce d'amusant, c'est que Ber,
je pense, le fait un peu la direction
générale des entreprises à Ber. Je pense
qu'en réalité les types qui sont dans la
soute à Berti à la DGE, ils connaissent
très bien le tissu économique secteur
par secteur. Simplement ceux qui sont en
charge des fusacion avec des banques
d'affaires en est d'autres qui euh qui
qui eux n'ont pas forcément envie qu'on
fasse ce ce ce repérage.
J'avais posé d'ailleurs cette question à
Emmanuel Macron quand il était ministre
de l'économie lors d'une de ses
auditions en commission des affaires éco
mais en disant mais bon pour pour qu'il
y ait pas un prochain alstom est-ce que
vous allez vous est-ce que vous avez
fait le repérage des entreprises
stratégiques qu'on ne veut pas vendre ?
Il m'avait répondu avec le sourire
d'ange qui peut avoir parfois. Ah
monsieur Marlex, c'est une très bonne
question. Oui oui, on va s'y employer,
on va on va faire ce repérage des
entreprises des entreprises
stratégiques. Bon, une fois encore, je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la DGE où il y a
des gens très compétent à euh à ce
repérage. Il suffit juste que il suffit
juste de vouloir de vouloir un peu mieux
protéger mais derrière comment dire de
se faire une doctrine c'est que là le
que le politique se fasse une doctrine
des secteurs sur lesquels on considère
que il faut des on ne tolère que des
investisseurs français ou des
investisseurs étrangers dans des
conditions extrêmement extrêmement
cadrées et extrêmement précises.
peut-être plus ou moins ce qui a été
fait avec le le le nouveau décret qui a
redéfini le champ des des
investissements des investissements
étrangers. Il y a encore quelques
secteurs sur lesquels on tâonne. Là, ils
viennent de s'interroger le gement
s'interroger sur la presse. Moi, je
pense qu'il faut rajouter le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire.
Vous savez, il y a un petit paradoxe,
c'est que les Européens ont 1000
secteurs agroalimentaires dans les
secteurs à protéger. En France, on l'a
pas fait. Moi, je pense qu'il faut qu'il
faut le faire. Regardez une boîte comme
Lactalis par exemple. Je crois que c'est
publie ses comptes là. Non,
c'est elle qui publie pas ses comptes.
Elle publie ses comptes elle. Non,
je elle fait partie fait preuve une
certaine discrétion sur ses comptes.
Oui. Euh en tout cas l'actalis ça doit
représenter je pas dire de bêtises entre
15 et 20 % je crois dans le de grandeur
de la collecte du lait en France. Voilà.
Imaginez ce qui se passe si demain la
famille Beignet décide de de vendre
cette boîte qui aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
est pas capitalisée pour pour très cher
par rapport à son chiffre d'affaires. Il
doit faire 20 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires. Euh
décide de vendre cette boîte aux
Chinois. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On
regarde partir notre notre lait. Euh on
a le même sujet sur sur les terres avec
des Chinois. et et l'exemple sur le
lait, il est pas totalement totalement
vain. Les Chinois viennent de faire une
acquisition euh en Australie aujourd'hui
d'un acteur d'un acteur majeur du lait.
Donc je pense qu'il faut dans dans les
secteurs, il faut rajouter euh euh
l'agro l'agroalimentaire comme l'Europe
d'ailleurs nous invite euh nous invite à
le faire. Donc il y a cette définition
des des secteurs et derrière il faut une
doctrine c'est qu'est-ce qu'on veut
faire le catalogue, ça suffit pas.
Qu'est-ce qu'on veut protéger et et quel
moyen quel moyen on met quels outils
juridiques on met en place à travers le
contrôle des des investissements
étrangers ? Après, il y a peut-être un
peut-être un second secteur sur lequel
on se dit bon bah là, OK, on admet des
des partenariats européens, c'est
l'histoire des champions européens. Moi,
je veux bien l'entendre. Je pense que
effectivement l'Europe l'Europe
puissance, elle doit passer aussi par un
espèce de colbertisme européen, mais il
est pas encore né. Et donc ça doit pas
être simplement l'Europe, l'Europe des
champions européens. C'est pas
simplement le rachat par les Allemands
des entreprises françaises. C'est euh
des des des géants sur un pied d'égalité
ou des mariage un peu en donnant comme
ça aurait pu être le cas d'ailleurs avec
entre Alstom et Siemins si on avait fait
un deal entre nucléaire et enfin pardon
énergie euh et ferroviaire. Bon c'est
pas c'est pas le choix qui qui avait été
fait. Donc le deuxème le deuxème rang
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec des
partenaires européens par exemple je
tout surprendre mais je trouve que le
mariage qui a organisé je pas c'est
monsieur Col pardon f attention à ce que
je dis qui a été organisé sous monsieur
Macron euh si je pense que monsieur
Coler était son directeur de cabinet
à Ber à ce moment-là sinon qu'il me
pardonne mais avec entre STX chantier
d'Atlantique et et Fantier par exemple
n'est pas forcément n'est pas forcément
un un non sens parce que on est entre
acteur européen, il fallait bien
quelqu'un, ça faisait longtemps que les
chantiers d'athlisque n'était plus
français et donc c'est pas forcément un
truc un truc idiot d'avoir un deuxième
niveau entre européen à condition que ce
soit pas à sens unique et que ce soit
pas que la France qui se qui se vende
comme dans ce mariage entrega qu'on
qu'on nous proposait entre entre Fiat et
Renault où le mariage entrego était tel
que que Fiat était deux fois plus
puissant que que Renault. Je sais pas ce
que j'appelle un mariage un mariage
entrega là était 7,5 l' était à 15 %.
Un commentaire d'un de nos internautes
qui doit être à la réunion. La DGA mais
son vé que quand vous faites des
conneries le plus grand malheur est la
prime que l'État l'État doit payer aux
entreprises en cas d'annulation des
contrats ou de republication d'une
activité, c'est du vol organisé.
Vous comprenez son commentaire ou pas ?
Je je je pense qu'il fait allusion
plutôt au contrat de de de licence
licences d'exportation qui un sujet que
je connais que que que je connais très
que je connais très mal euh et pas au
dispositif d'investissement dans une
entreprise. Donc c'est plutôt sur les
contrats de d'export où j'imagine
effectivement que lorsque la DGA dit à
une boîte non n'y allait pas
fait des conneries où n'y allait pas
avec ce pays-là. Euh oui, ça doit
pouvoir euh créer quelques petits
préjudices de à l'entreprise. Bon,
après, il y a aussi euh il y a aussi euh
le risque du préjudice, on en a pas
parlé, mais euh vaut mieux éviter
d'aller vendre, c'est pour se faire
taper derrière par les Américains par
exemple euh si on va commercer en Iran
alors que les Américains nous ont
demandé de de ne pas le faire. Je je
repasse débat parce qu'il est il
pourrait nous emmener dans dans
plusieurs heures de de discussion. Non,
je je voudrais terminer. Euh donc c'est
un vrai sujet mais sincèrement moi je je
le connais pas.
Peugeot c'était bien en Iran. J'ai
jamais été ministre de la défense et
donc j'ai aucune pratique de j'ai jamais
contrôlé ces ces sujets-là euh sur sur
le contrôle de de de nos entreprises.
Donc il y a cette ce degré de contrôle
ce qu'on appelle non capitalistique. Moi
je trouve ça assez intéressant d'avoir
un élément qui en réalité ne coûte rien
qui nous permet de de faire de de faire
valoir les intérêts de la puissance
publique, de défendre les intérêts de la
nation sans que ça coûte 1 € à la
nation. Ça c'est parfaitement adapté à
l'état en fait de dont vous me parliez
tout à l'heure. Donc ça ce contrôle euh
ce ce contrôle juridique euh il est il
est très intéressant. Ensuite il y a
évidemment euh un peu de contrôle
capitalistique. Alors là on a un vrai
problème parce que si on sort du secteur
stratégique et que malgré tout on est
attaché à une boîte et qu'on aimerait
qu'elle qu'elle ne foute pas le camp de
France euh qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Et là,
ça renvoie à la faiblesse en France,
enfin comment dire, à la au
dépérissement du malgré tout du
capitalisme du capitalisme français. Euh
certains ont employé l'expression de
capitalisme sans capital. Oui,
malheureusement c'est c'est un peu la
situation de la France. Alors, on va pas
refaire l'historique mais c'est la
particularité dans laquelle dans
laquelle on est. C'està-dire que demain,
on a besoin de trouver un partenaire.
Alors, on a eu besoin par exemple de
trouver un partenaire pour reprendre
Alstom à la place de l'État. Bon bah,
heureusement qu'il y a eu euh qu' a eu
Martin Big pour euh pour se dévouer sur
sur euh sur cette opération parce que
qui avait la capacité en France euh à le
faire ? Euh il y avait pas il y avait
pas beaucoup d'investisseurs français
euh possible. pour regarder les
difficultés qu'on a eu sur le plan de
sauvetage de de Peugeot où il a fallu
aller chercher un partenaire chinois
pour pour investir du cash. Alors, il y
a donc ce ce problème de de capitalisme,
on ne changera pas du jour au lendemain
et je veux bien que on améliore la la la
fiscalité
sur sur les dividendes comme l'a fait
monsieur Macron. Je regrette juste que
ce soit les retraités français qui qui
l'ai payé cette cette flat taxe. Euh
mais je pense que voilà où je bien
croire en la théorie du ruissellement
mais à ce rythme-là, il va falloir quand
même plusieurs générations avant de
recréer un capitalisme français. Euh
si si d'ailleurs il y a il y a plus de
de génération une question si si tout ça
pourrait être donc bref en tout cas faut
trouver une situation une réponse une
réponse urgente. Moi je pense que la
réponse urgente c'est c'est prolonger ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a ce qui a été fait à
l'initiative de Nicolas Sarkozy et noter
le bien je seule fois je dirais du bien
de François Hollande par François
Hollande je veux dire la création du FSI
euh par Nicolas Sarkozi le le fond
stratégique d'investissement qui a été
créé dans le grand emprunt grâce au
grâce au grand emprunt qui à l'époque a
dû être doté de mémoire de 8 ou 9
milliards d'euros et qui a été
transformé après sous François Hollande
avec une fusion avec Oo en la banque
publique d'investissement. Cette banque
publique d'investissement aujourd'hui,
elle a un niveau d'engagement dans
l'économie française qui est de de de
mémoire, si une bêtise, je vais mêre
corrigé par un internaute, je crois de
de l'ordre de 30 milliards.
Donc c'est un truc qui donc aujourd'hui
n'est pas totalement inintéressant. Sauf
que ces 30 milliards, en clair, ça
permet de prendre des participations
intéressantes soit dans des dans des
dans des start-ups, dans des fonds
d'innovation, soit dans des PME, soit
dans des belles ETI. Ça permet pas
vraiment d'aller au-delà des ETI. Donc
il faut qu'on imagine autre chose. Et
pour moi le le le autre chose euh je
qu'on doit imaginer
le le le plus rapidement possible, c'est
l'équivalent d'un vrai d'un vrai fond
souverain. Euh c'est un vrai fond
souverain, un vrai fond stratégique à la
française.
Pourquoi la pourquoi la BPI a autorisé
le la vente de technique ?
Pourquoi ? Pardon ?
Pourquoi la BPI a a autorisé la vente de
techni ?
Écoutez, je pas conseil d'administration
de de de la de la de la BPI. Euh euh
ouais la la la euh ça fait partie des
ventes sur lesquelles on a qu'on a un
peu regardé pas pas pas malheureusement
très en détail parce qu'une fois encore
en 6 mois dans la commission d'enquête
on avait pas le temps de de de tout
décortiquer. C'est une vente
effectivement qui est assez étrange
parce qu'en clair c'est
Technipp était en bien meilleure santé
que que FMC donc les l'américain qui l'a
racheté et donc les conditions de ce
deal sont effectivement assez assez
étranges. Mais sincèrement, j'ai pas eu
le temps de de de travailler
suffisamment sur ce sujet pour avoir un
avis un avis définitif. Euh voilà, je
sais qu'il pose encore des questions et
et euh que payer en tout cas la la
OK. En terme de préconisation
la bénim et tout ça, c'est encore la
période la période macron. Donc je pense
que le le le vrai sujet aujourd'hui ici
pour pour finir de défendre quelques
fleurons stratégiques, ce qui nous reste
encore, c'est un vrai fond souverain
doté non pas de de 30 milliards comme
comme l'ABP aujourd'hui mais doté de de
200 à 300 milliards d'euros.
D'accord. Mais mais des gars la tête des
des vrais patriotes, des gens qui vont
piloter ça
issu d'écoles qui forment l'élite de la
France pour la France pour les intérêts
français. Tout ça, tout ça existe en
France et tout ça a existé. Tout ça a
existait. C'est on a eu j une date assez
récente. Moi, je suis assez frappé de
voir que avec la disparition du
ministère de l'industrie, enfin
ministère de l'industrie euh vous aviez
des XPON qui connaissaient quand même
très très bien le monde industriel,
l'équivalent de ce qui reste d'ailleurs
à la DGA euh et des des gens qui étaient
assez passionnés par par par leur
mission et par cette défense de de de de
cette de cette production, de cet
héritage en terme de de de savoir-faire
industriel et tout ça a disparu avec le
ministère de l'industrie. Aujourd'hui,
c'est ministère de l'économie des
finances qui qui mène sa loi. Euh les
seigneurs sont les inspecteurs des
finances. on a gardé quelques
polytechniciens dans la soute quand les
inspecteurs des finances comprennent pas
trop les trucs techniques comme ça ils
ont des mecs pour leur faire des pour
leur faire des notes. Mais voilà, je dis
tout ça en souriant mais je pense que
c'est pas très loin de la de de la façon
dont ça dont ça fonctionne. Euh bref
donc oui, il faut retrouver un corps il
faut retrouver un corps
d'administrateurs
euh qu'il soient des gens qui croient en
l'industrie française, qui croient en ce
patrimoine économique, je pense une fois
encore qu'il existe. Qu'il soient des
gens aussi qui connaissent connaissent
l'industrie qui a des patients.
Bon d'accord, on l'a déjà dit 25 fois.
Voilà le le vrai sujet le vrai sujet
quand même c'est comment on trouve 300
milliards
si on savait trouver 300 milliards sur
pas un cheval on l'aurait fait je pense
depuis longtemps. Donc il faut le faire.
On se fait un petit braquage chez les
bét en cours.
Non moi je pense que
je pense que ça va ça va un peu auelà
au-delà de de de de leur fortune. Euh et
donc je pense que je pense que le sujet
c'est c'est de mobiliser les paragnes
des français. C'est que si on n pas de
fond si on a pas de
un grand tremprint
non si on n pas de fond souverain si on
a pas de fonds souverain en France c'est
parce que on n pas de de rente
pétrolière par exemple
comme les les Norvégiens ou et cetera
euh
les Norvégiens du sud là comment ils
s'appelle
c'est ça ou de Qatar de Coette Qatar
c'est le gaz mais enfin bon euh bon et
que hein et on n pas non plus de système
de retraite par capitalisation qui
permet de d'accumuler nous on
redistribue tout avec notre système par
répartition en instanté. On a juste un
peu de de retraite complémentaires qu'on
est capable de de de stocker.
Parce que là où en revanche que la
particularité de la France c'est quand
même c'est quand même qu'on a 5000 5000
milliards grosso modo d'épargne des
Français qui
pardon
qui à partir
on a 5000 milliards d'épargne des
français notamment des placements dans
dans l'assurance vie
qui qui c'est de la merde pure et simple
l'assurance vie c'est baqué sur des
obligations d'état s' un état fait c'est
ce qui d'assez fascinant c'est-à-dire
que on a un système aujourd'hui qui est
totalement aburrent c'estàd que là où
les français placentur argent à long
terme
l'assurance vie et bien les assureurs
aujourd'hui sont un peu contraints par
les règles notamment les directives
c'est la directive solvency sur les
placements des des sur les règles de
fond propre en fait des assureurs. Donc
en réalité ils ont intérêt à à les
placer à court terme en bon du trésor.
Donc en fait on a on a un système
aujourd'hui qui est totalement aberrent
négatif les Français où les Français
profitent l'épargne à long terme à des
institution dans lesquelles ils ont
confiance et que à cause de la bêtise de
nos règles, cette épargne de très long
terme, on le rend totalement liquide et
on le transforme en épargne à court
terme. Donc ça est totalement aberrent
et donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on qu'on
invente un produit financier. Pour le
coup, on a quand même des gens hyper
compétents aujourd'hui en ingénierie
financière dans ce pays. que ça me ça
suppose peut-être de modifier un tout
petit peu la directive européenne sur
sur Solvency mais je pense que c'est pas
totalement infaisable pour inventer un
produit de collecte d'épargne de long
terme fléché justement sur ce fond
souverain. Je pense que les Français
sont suffisamment attachés à leur à leur
industrie pour pour jouer le jeu en plus
d'alimenter ce type de placement qui
pourrait être doté de d'avantages
fiscaux dont on sait doter certains
certains certains l'assurance vie
notamment certains produits de
placement. Donc voilà, je pense qu'on a
en réalité euh une solution assez facile
euh à mettre en œuvre et tant qu'on aura
pas fait, tant qu'on aura pas un fond
souverain doté de de 200 à 300 milliards
d'euros, euh je pense qu'on y arrivera
pas.
Les Norvégiens du Nord là, c'est 1000
milliards qu'ils ont, non ? C'est ça.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est 1000 milliards.
Franchement, on passerait déjà de 30
milliards à 200 ou 300 milliards. Je
pense qu'avec 300 milliards d'euros, on
arrive déjà à faire des choses beaucoup
plus intéressantes.
On arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
interview. Euh quelques mots sur le RIC,
ça vous parle le RIC ?
Oui, bien sûr. Le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne.
Je fais partie des des des
députés. Moi, j'ai déposé une
proposition de loi pour
On va la faire courte he on commence pas
à la faire façon politicien genre moi,
je fille et ainsi de suite.
C'est bien, c'est pas bien. Oui. Non,
non. Oui. Euh
oui, parce que de toute façon, enfin je
pense qu'on est dans une époque où il
faut associer différemment et plus
régulièrement le les Français, le peuple
à la à la décision. Euh pas le faire
n'importe comment sans n'importe quoi.
Faut pas évidemment se payer leur figure
dans la façon dont on dont on les
consulte. Faut donc leur donner la
possibilité de de de s'autosaisir
eux-mêmes euh de certains sujets. Moi,
j'appelle ça référendum d'initiative
populaire et pas citoyen parce que
citoyen c'est un endroit euh
je je je sais ce que c'est qu'un
français, je sais pas ce que c'est qu'un
citoyen. Le citoyen en général enfin
c'est c'est c'est normalement dans notre
droit, c'est aussi les étrangers. Bon et
donc moi j'ai pas forcément envie que
des étrangers, je suis un peu cohérent
avec moi-même, que des étrangers
viennent que soit chinois, américain ou
d'autres nationalités euh puisse
participer à ce dispositif que je veux
réserver euh aux Français. Donc c'est
pour ça que j'appelle ça référendum
initiative populaire. Je pense que dans
dans dans notre pays, notamment pour le
gauliste que je suis euh où la 5e
République, elle a été construite avec
un un système de euh un système de de de
double légitimité, une représentation
euh parlementaire d'un côté, mais aussi
la légitimité du recours du recours au
peuple. Euh et donc je pense qu'il faut
pas avoir peur de combiner les deux.
Sarco avec la révision de 2008 avait
fait un pas avec le référendum
d'initiative populaire. J'espère sur ADP
euh qu'on arrivera pour la première fois
à le mettre euh à le mettre en œuvre.
Oui, je fais partie de ceux qui avaient
signé en tant que député
sur internet. Donc je fais d'abord
partie de ceux qui ont signé euh pour
pour que les enfin pour que les
parlementaires le nombre requisit de
parlementaires permettent d'enclencher
la procédure et ensuite j'ai signé comme
citoyen évidemment et à ma permanence
j'invite pour les les habitants de
drogue qui n'ont pas de ma
circonscription qui n'ont pas accès à
internet à venir signer à ma permanence
on leur met un ordinateur à disposition
et et on les aide et on les aide à
faire. Donc oui, je pense qu'il faut
rééquilibrer aujourd'hui le mode le le
mode d'expression. Il faut pas opposer
faut pas opposer populisme et enfin la
représentation du peuple en direct avec
la représentation la représentation
parlementaire. J'ai j'ai lu un article
un peu étrange de de de Zemour. C'est
vrai que ce qui se passe de qui ? J'ai
pas entendu
de Zemour. Ce qui ce qui se passe en
Italie, Grande-Bretagne, paraît étrange,
mais il en tiré une conclusion un peu
trop générale qui était grosso modo la
démocratie. Je crois que sa phrase,
c'était euh "La démocratie parlementaire
joue son plus mauvais rôle en invalidant
les décisions du peuple, quoi. Euh
notamment avec la coalition italienne
qui juge contre nature et cetera et qui
qui a mis dehors ce pauvre ce pauvre
Salvini. Moi je me dis, je modère un
tout petit peu son son propos. Je me dis
moi j'aurais je pense que si en
Allemagne en 1933
on a vu une une coalition parlementaire
futelle contre nature pour empêcher le
chancelier Adolf Hitler de prendre le
pouvoir, ça aurait peut-être pas été
plus mal quand même. Donc la la
représentation parlementaire, elle peut
aussi quand même avoir un rôle à jouer.
Il faut pas faut pas opposer les deux et
c'est pour ça que je suis favorable au
référendum d'initiative populaires.
Comment vous expliquez la défiance des
Français face au monde politique ? C'est
à cause de Balcani
Cusac
ou que simplement vous respectiez jamais
votre programme.
Ça, je peux pas vous laisser dire que
qu'on qu'on respecte jamais notre
programme parce que je pense que il y a
moi cosmétique. D'accord.
J'ai Non, j'ai j'ai servi un président
de la République qui s'appelait Nicolas
Sarkozy et j'ai écrit un livre. Alors,
il est épuisé donc je profite pas de
votre de votre média pour le pour le
vendre. qui paraît que c'est une très
bonne recette de parler de son livre.
Euh,
vous avez touché combien pour ce livre ?
Euh, j'ai rien touché parce que je crois
que mon éditeur a fait faillite peu de
temps, peu de temps après. Euh, non,
mais très clairement, j'ai écris un
livre à l'époque d'ailleurs pour pour
dire pour dire le bilan de Nicolas
Sarkozy, il a pas fait fit à cause de
moi, je vous rassure. Euh non, je pense
que par exemple Nicolas Sarkozi est un
président de la République qui a qui est
vraiment a c'est efforcé malgré les
difficultés économiques à tenir à tenir
ses promesses. La promesse du pouvoir
d'achat et d'essayer d'attenir accision
supplémentaire. euh la promesse de de la
maîtrise de l'immigration, il a essayé
de la tenir euh avec euh il y a eu sous
son sous son quinquena une vraie
inversion de la courbe de des courbes
migratoires, une vraie inversion. Je dis
pas que le stock de population
évidemment qui est là euh il est en
France et le devoir c'est de c'est de
l'intégrer. C'est un autre sujet mais il
y a eu donc enfin on a des présidents
qui ont essayé de de de tenir leurs
promesses. Euh voilà, ça a pas été le
cas de tous. Euh monsieur Macron a très
habilement joué sur tout ça en venimer
euh ce cette idée que que personne
n'aurait jamais tenu ses promesses. Euh
je pense que Hollande a été pour
beaucoup quand même à défaire un peu
systématiquement ce qu'avait fait son
prédécesseur.
Donc la défiance.
Euh oui. Non mais tout ça effectivement
a fini par donner un sentiment d'un
pouvoir politique stérile. Je pense
qu'après il y a j'ai le phénomène il est
il est pas que français le phénomène
Balkini c'est bien qu'il soit en prison
ce soir ou pas ?
Je pense qu'il y a quand même un un cas
de fraude fiscale
plus qu'avér massif. Euh et donc je
pense que
je suis pas un ami personnel de Patrick
Balcani, je c'est un parlementaire que
j'ai croisé dans mon dans mon groupe
dans le précédent
précédent quinquena. Euh voilà, donc je
dirais pas comme Nicolas Sarkozi, j'ai
de la peine pour lui. Euh je connais pas
assez intimement pour ça. Je pense que
je pense que il est normal que la
justice soit passée euh au passage.
Effectivement, je pense qu'il faut pour
que la justice passe jusqu'au bout, il
faut pas que qu'il ait l'air d'être
d'être le seul lampiste à payer à un
moment. J'observe que les seuls hommes
politiques d'ailleurs euh qui soient
jamais là en prison ces dernières
années, c'est quand même plutôt c'est
toujours des hommes politiques de droite
d'ur il y a eu Carignon euh qui à
l'époque euh il est pas allé pour par
hasard pardon
comment il s'appelait son petit prénom
Carignon.
Alain Carignan pardon. Non non mais
voilà, on a on a eu donc faudrait pas
que que qu'il n'y ait jamais que des
hommes politiques de droite qui aillent
réellement réellement en prison quoi.
C'est c'est juste la
un petit bracelet électronique, ça vous
irait bien
la petite remarque. La petite à qui à
moi. Non, la petite remarque. La petite
remarque que je non, je pense très
clairement moi j'ai pas de j'ai pas de
de de complaisance particulière. Je
pense qu'il faut que la justice passe.
Mais il faut qu'elle qu'elle le fasse
pour tout le monde.
Est-ce qu'il faut arrêter les cellules
VIP ? Est-ce qu'il faut arrêter les
bracelets électrodiques sur les rivages
de Corse ?
Oui, je sais pas. Vous savez, moi je
trouve que
est-ce que l'affaire Balcani c'est faire
passer un signal aux français maintenant
et surtout aux politiques.
Maintenant on vous
grave que ça. Plus grave que ça. Je
pense qu'on est dans un pays où
aujourd'hui savez on on a fait voter
d'ailleurs beaucoup de lois de
moralisation de la vie politique et on
met bêtement bêtement le le le curseur
sur les parlementaires comme si un
député comme si ça servait à quelque
chose de corrompre un député sauf à être
président de l'Assemblée nationale,
président d'une commission, rapporteur
d'un texte. Franchement, je conseille au
lobbist de mettre leur argent ailleurs
parce que le pouvoir d'influence d'un
député,
je sais pas, n'importe quel chef de
bureau dans un ministère sur un texte
beaucoup plus d'influence.
Les chefs de bureau dans un ministère,
ils sont surveillés par les les
renseignants ou pas ?
J'en sais rien. Je peux pas répondre pas
répondre à votre à votre question.
J'imagine qu'on a des secteurs très
sensibles, c'est ça doit ça doit être le
cas. Mais
avec quoi
mais pas sur des sujets pas sur des
sujets non moins sensibles. Non,
effectivement, c'est un sans doute un
contreexemple. Enfin,
mais ce que j'observe c'est que dans la
vie dans la vie locale aujourd'hui par
exemple, j'ai l'occasion de de de dire
au ministre de l'intérieur par exemple,
moi mon mon inquiétude à titre personnel
sur la disparition du contrôle de
l'égalité dans ce pays. Donc je pense
qu'on est en train de recréer une
génération de problèmes de de
corruption, de d'élite favoritisme dans
nos collectivités locales aujourd'hui
parce que il y a plus de contrôle de
l'égalité. on réduit des effectifs en
préfecture, on leur demande de faire
autre chose. Moi, j'ai j'ai eu
l'occasion il y a pas très longtemps de
d'évoquer ce des sujets de sujets de de
marché qui me paraissait pas très sain
avec avec une préfette euh et elle m'a
répondu euh euh je veux pas savoir,
faites un article 40. J'ai quand même
rappelé que c'était la première de de
ces missions en terme de contrôle de
l'égalité, de vérifier les marchés
publics. Voilà. Euh bon et euh le
procureur les procureurs de la
République euh localement il préfèrent
souvent se boucher les oreilles plutôt
que de que de risquer de se frosser avec
des Donc on est en en réalité encore
dans une situation qui est qui est loin
d'être réglée dans dans notre pays.
C'est une petite parenthèse dans dans
votre sujet. Donc pardon, mais la
défiance elle va elle va au-delà de ces
problèmes de de de ces problèmes de de
de de de de de comportement individuel.
C'est évident que il est évident qu'
font tâche les problèmes de comportement
individuel. Moi, j'avoue que je suis
j'étais assez mal à l'aise aujourd'hui
de siéger à l'Assemblée nationale avec
un président de la République
euh mis en examen dans une
un président non un président de
l'Assemblée par un président de
l'Assemblée nationale mis en examen dans
Prenez pas vos rêves pour des réalités
dans une dans une affaire de pardon euh
dans dans dans une affaire qui sur
laquelle je j'observe qu'il a jamais
contesté les les fêtes qui sont
présentées quoi.
qui semble assez lisible. Donc tout tout
ça sincèrement me met me met
effectivement assez mal assez mal à
l'aise. Mais pardon mais pardon, je
pense que le problème de défiance, il va
il vient de de bien plus loin et il
renvoie aussi à des questions à des
questions économiques, à des questions
européennes. Je pense que notamment en
Europe,
en Europe la ce qu'on a laissé faire au
sein de l'Union européenne depuis
notamment depuis l'élargissement
européen qui vraiment a été le grand
chamboulement pour moi de de de l'Union
européenne, en clair l'élargissement qui
a permis le déménagement du jour au
lendemain de pont entiers de notre de
notre industrie vers les pays d'Europe
de l'Est. élargissement voulu par les
Allemands, imposé par les Allemands qui
eux ont su en tirer plutôt profit de
manière très intelligente en
délocalisant en utilisant la Tchéquie
pays qui connaissaient bien pardon le
leur base arrière ou enfin en tout cas
pour les Allemands pour l'industrie
allemande ça a été très profitable pour
l'industrie française et pour d'autres
pays ça a été cet élargissement a été
catastrophique en terme économique et
donc je pense pardon que ce que les ce
que les peuples font reprochent aussi à
leurs élites politiques c'est de ne pas
les avoir assez protégés et que
notamment dans cette mondialisation,
l'Europe a été un accélérateur euh de la
mondialisation, un accélérateur euh du
déménagement euh plutôt que quoi aux
dernières élections présidentielles ou
de tour de protection dont on aurait eu
besoin ? Pardon ?
Au deuxème tour de l'élection
présidentielle, vous avez voté quoi ?
Moi, j'ai voté blanc. Excusez-moi, mais
je je ne crois ni au mondialisme face au
Macron, ni au localisme de de de Marine
Le Pen. Donc je pense qu'il aurait ruiné
ce pays. Les républicains, il en reste
quoi ?
Écoutez, il en reste le premier groupe
d'opposition à l'Assemblée nationale.
C'est pas rien. Le premier groupe
d'opposition, ça sert quand même d'avoir
le premier groupe d'opposition à
l'Assemblée nationale. Voyez, on arrive
de temps en temps à faire des
commissions d'enquête pas inutile. Euh
le le Sénat, ce qui permet aussi de
d'être un vrai contrepouvoir. Il y a eu
des commissions d'enquête là aussi sur
sur Benala. On a freiné une réforme
constitutionnelle, une réforme
constitutionnelle qui aurait pu être
assez catastrophique pour pour ce pays.
Je peux comprendre qu'elle n'irait pas
au bout grâce grâce au Sénat. Voilà.
Euh euh
il en reste quoi ? Par contre, très
sincèrement, je pense que effectivement
on a dans les 2 ans euh un un corpus
idéologique à reconstruire. Moi, je dis
une fois encore, pardon, de de de me
répéter, mais je crois ni au mondialisme
Béat de Macron que je pense totalement
daté euh et tous ceux qui nous disent
"Mais la droite ne sait plus où elle
habite. Convertissez-vous au
néolibéralisme de de de Macron, comment
ça vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec lui
Alors qu' alors qu'il privatise euh oui,
c'est par là c'est la phrase de Bruno
Lemè à la droite c'est plus où elle
habite parce que elle refuse une
privatisation. Pardon ? J'ai envie de
lui rappeler euh Bruno, souviens-toi que
c'est le général de Gaulle qui a fait
les nationalisations en 1945 euh et
souviens-toi que la droite n'a privatisé
pour l'essentiel en 86 93 que ce que la
gauche avait avait nationalisé. Donc on
n'est pas dans la religion du tout
privatisation.
On avait dit qu'on battait pas le record
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce soir de 2h40 et
des poussières. Donc là, on doit être à
peu près à 2h25.
Vous me tentez ?
Et euh on arrive à la fin de notre
interview.
Vous avez vraiment l'envie de favoriser
Mélenchon quoi, de pouvoir continuer à
dire que c'était lui.
Bah et je me fais un peu moins chier
avec Mélenchon qu'avec vous quoi. Tout à
fait honnête.
Il fallait pas me provoquer, hein. Et
euh donc on arrive à la fin de notre Bah
ouais, tu trouves, tu cherches, hein. Tu
cherches, tu trouve. On arrive à la fin
de notre interview euh euh qui se
termine par laisser un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Euh et puis si vous aviez trois bouquins
à nous conseiller juste avant ce conseil
pour les jeunes générations, quelque
chose d'impérissable qui va rester sur
sur internet. Waouh, c'est difficile.
Trois bouquins.
Peut-être commencer par les trois
bouquins. Je vais penser à mesures, à
mesures d'été.
Ben, je parlais des mémoires d'espoir du
général de Gaulle. Je pense que c'est
euh c'est quand même une bonne lecture
parce que ça ça rappelle ça rappelle ce
qu'a été la situation de la France à une
époque la 4e République euh pays en
faillite économiquement
vraiment l'état en faillite de façon euh
dont on l'évoquait capable de de boucler
ses budgets et ça raconte enfin état qui
ne croyait plus en rien où les élites
n'en avaient que pour le transnational
le supranational pardon euh et ça montre
comment finalement ce pays a su inverser
totalement la tendance et le général de
Gour raconte ça parfaitement de manière
extrêmement vivante et avec une certaine
de vue. Donc c'est vraiment un
formidable un formidable livre. Euh
euh un deuxème un deuxième livre
l'histoire intellectuelle du libéralisme
de de Pierre Manantan qui est un livre
que que j'aime bien que j'aime bien
relire. Je crois que l'idée de liberté
dans notre pays, elle est évidemment
fondatrice et et euh et moi qui viens de
plaider pendant ces ce trop longtemps
euh pour un certain rôle de l'État, je
crois quand même que enf faut jamais
qu'on oublie que de mon point de vue la
valeur souveraine c'est la liberté ce
qui nous différencie des mes collègues
communistes ou France insoumise qui qui
préfèrent sans doute qui mettent surtout
qui mettent probablement en avant l'idée
d'égalité. Euh donc je reste
fondamentalement libéral mais voilà faut
se remettre un peu en tête ce que ce
qu'est réellement l'idée l'idée libérale
dans dans dans notre dans notre pays.
Le troisème c'est dur parce que c'est le
dernier donc
et donc il y en a il y en a beaucoup.
Allez c'est j'allais citer Standal parce
que pour moi c'est l'esprit français.
Vous me parlez de culture française et
dans un tout autre registre. C'est bien
de se rappeler de ce qu'est le génie le
génie français. Euh je citerai pas je je
serai pas de noir parce que je pense que
c'est para que c'est des bouquins
fétiches de Macron. Euh
et alors
non allez la charthos de parme. Alors
voilà trois livres trois livres. Cseils
pour les pour les futures générations.
Un un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Un seul conseil là c'est dur.
Encus un politique.
Je crois que vaut mieux avoir lu avant.
Vaut mieux avoir lu avant. Non.
Euh oui, enfin
ça m'embête parce que j'ai pas de
répéter quand même ce que vous venez de
me dire. Non mais mais fondamentalement
moi c'est d'ailleurs c'est tout le sens
de ma de ma très misérable et modeste et
modeste existence. Moi je crois
fondamentalement
en la volonté politique au pouvoir
politique. Je pense que tout le sens de
la politique c'est ça doit vraiment être
la la volonté. croire qu'il y a besoin
de volonté politique pour changer les
choses. Donc ce qui explique d'ailleurs
ma ma petite nuance par rapport
par rapport aux ultralibéraux et et et
au laisser faire euh on n pas le droit
de se désintéresser. On n pas le droit
de croire qu' que le marché que c'est
qu'il y a que ça de quelque chose de
vrai. Les choses les choses elles
peuvent très vite mal tourner dans le
monde quoi. Je dirais, on l'a vu une
période qui est pas si éloignée qui est
qui qui est les années qui est les
années 30
et donc et donc je crois qu'on a on a
pas d'excuses si on ne s'engage pas. Euh
je pense qu'il vaut mieux faire de la
politique
mal, c'estàdire dans une famille
politique qui est pas la mienne que de
ne pas en faire que de pas en faire du
tout quoi. Enfin que ne pas s'engager du
tout. Euh après, c'est bien de se
renseigner euh un tout petit peu et ce
qui a de formidable avec euh des médias
euh comme le vôtre qui offrent des temps
longs, c'est que effectivement euh je
dirais on le temps de se renseigner un
peu à profondeur et de sortir de de ce
ce drame assez abétissant qui est le
système médiatique euh actuel où euh où
on n' de prise que ce qui est ce qui est
scandaleux, que ce soit vrai ou pas.
Et on construit rien, on construit rien
comme ça.
Olivier Marlex, merci. Merci pour cette
commission d'enquête où vous avez bien
bosser et au plaisir de vous retrouver
une prochaine fois.
Merci de votre invitation.
Coupez.
[Musique]